ron desantis is threatening to pull
disney's special governing status or
whatever that means apparently since i
think the 60s they've been able to
govern their own property as if it's
their own
government
and because they've been supporting
wokeness and because they've been
sporting
i'll just call it child grooming
desantis has basically said i don't see
why we shouldn't pull their why they
should have the status and several
republicans in the state are talking
about pulling it because well it seems
like if there are
at least some politicians who are doing
anything in the culture war it's just
the people in florida uh it's probably
fair to say there are several other
states that are doing awesome stuff i'm
hearing what is it georgia's doing
constitutional carry texas just did it a
bunch of other states are doing it
florida might be doing these are really
really cool things so we'll talk about
that we'll talk about how this is now
turning into a major culture war
movement with the daily wire launching a
new kids programming uh uh
format channel or whatever 100 million
dollars and a lot of pushback from
female athletes over the trans issue in
sports the female athletes are now
starting to speak up and having a big
impact so it's friday we're going to be
chilling jen sackey is quitting
apparently and i don't think anybody
really cares all that much i just
shrugged when i heard and i'm like sure
whatever and uh joining us today on this
lovely friday to talk about all of it is
michael malus aloha
you want us to say something yeah you
introduce yourself oh hi i'm michael
malus star stage and screen that's
correct i just want to give a shout out
to adrian curry um and to elizabeth
who's in columbia today uh who are you
what do you do
they know who i am well but there may be
new viewers okay i i am uh what uh
author my last book is the anarchist
handbook tim did a chapter for the
audiobook which is at
anarchistaudioblock.com yeah that's cool
anarchisthanbook.com for the book uh
hardcover is coming out soon my next
book's called the white pill i needed a
book on the new right and deer reader is
the book on north korea and you can
follow me on twitter at michael ballas
all right we got james amazing i'm
seamus coughlin i run a youtube channel
called freedom tunes if you all want to
go check that out we release a new
cartoon every single thursday sometimes
on tuesdays we just released a video on
this first topic we're talking about
which is uh these men competing in
women's sports i think you all will
enjoy it
ian crossland over here i want you to
respect yourself find love
that's a great message thanks michael i
just want to go to my youtube channel
it's actually a lot easier it's a lot
easier to just click subscribe at
freedom tunes so yes i wanted to say
this is our 500th episode and we have
michael malus and i'm loving it it's
going to be a great evening yes yeah and
stay tuned for the bonus section
we don't do this on friday well that's
why they should stay tuned yeah
all right all right ladies and gentlemen
before we get started we have an awesome
sponsor virtual shield head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can get 50 off your light uh a
lifetime discount for your virtual
private network service it's a basic
layer of defense for you as you browse
the web it keeps prying eyes away
hackers government agents corporations
it makes it very difficult or more
difficult for them to spy on you head
over to surfing internet safe and
virtual shield is a service compatible
with all devices it allows you to browse
the web safely securely and anonymously
using their global network of servers
and private ips
virtual shield lets you browse the web
completely anonymously so the big name
isps and other third parties will not be
able to monitor and sell your activity
and browsing history when using uh
virtual shields virtual private network
service your traffic is routed through
their secure and encrypted servers that
means any restrictions censorship blocks
on your internet is bypassed it's
completely free for 30 days available on
mac windows iphone ipad android or
chrome does all the work for you to keep
you safe and secure it even encrypts
your wifi connection blocking hackers
maybe even near you so again shout out
to virtual shield thanks so much for
sponsoring the show surfing
internetsafe.com and don't forget head
over to timcast.com become members to
support our work directly you keep all
of our journalists employed we are a
member-funded website and you will get
access to exclusive episodes of the tim
castro podcast with our guests monday
through thursday at 8pm only for members
so again sign up at timcast.com but
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends right now and let's
talk about that first story can i say
something before we get to that yeah i
hope at some point during the show you
guys look back at like the 500 episodes
and because i think that's an important
thing to kind of get a little meta like
how the show's grown what have you
learned what advice you'll probably give
to people who are enjoying this that's
the i mean that's the kind of thing i
think people are interested in 500 it's
no joke you know that's a good point i
don't really think about stuff like this
you know to like do a look back
and prepare something
maybe we should we could do like you
know who who's that lady who's who sings
a song about remembering you somebody
else
yeah yeah ladies mclaughlin
you know what we could have done it
would have been funny is if we just
showed the past episodes with michael
yeah and we did like a slow motion yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we should let's do a live stream where
we watch all 500 episodes
you know as an aside there was this
woman who wrote she wrote this thing
called the alternative influencer
network oh yeah and she was in a book it
was like a report okay for like a
non-profit where she smears oh yeah yeah
yeah it was a crazy conspiracy theory
thing where she had a bunch of different
youtube channels that have nothing to do
with each other connected with red lines
yeah yeah so uh but like it connected
chris raygun to richard spencer right
like chris raygun is like a culture
commentary guy who plays video games and
richard spencer is richard spencer and
like there's a line connecting him and
even he was like what like they've never
even said each other's names before can
i show my age
there was someone named mark fabiani who
worked for the democratic party for
hillary in some capacity and he did this
in the 90s he created this big flow
chart of everyone pointing to you know
cato institute and this one's in bed so
that's why when hillary clinton went on
i believe is good morning america and
said with this huge blowback there's
this vast right-wing conspiracy against
my pres i guess my husband and it's on
the open she wasn't just talking about
her ass she was referencing this
document that they had so this has been
going on for a long time well here's the
best part and why bring it up is that i
complained very heavily about it because
it put me right in the middle and like
the young turks did a segment on it
where it's like tim poole is the center
they were talking about me but it like
makes me the center of this vast you
know alt-right conspiracy or something
and i was just like it's fabricated i
had friends who were working in these
media companies who even rejected the
story out right because i reached out to
them like hey guys look at this and i
pointed it out they're like whoa like
people worked at the atlantic and
politico and so she does a follow-up so
then she's specifically on me tim
controls she's dynamic in politico she
does a follow-up specifically on me
where she says she watched all of my
videos
which is the most insane thing anyone's
ever done is that literally possible if
you turn them all on at the same time
yeah nobody drives you insane
hold on hold on this was 2000 uh like 19
i think yeah so this was before irl but
this meant that there were
two hours of content every day for like
three years
so that would that meant that to get
this done it was like in the span of a
year
she had to watch my content she had to
watch like four days worth of content
every day to keep up with the content i
was producing and she referenced a whole
bunch of my old content now far be it
for me to call her a liar she said she
watched it all right i am impressed yeah
and then she ultimately concluded that
like i wasn't that bad and wasn't far
right or something like that it was the
weirdest
trying to take me down or maybe just
like i did a deep dive understand
this is the longest suicide note i have
ever because if someone is sitting down
and watching your content for like a
year my god that is a cry for help but
is it not interesting
but is it not interesting that the
person who actually sat down and
consumed all of your content ended up
walking away going okay he's not
something like far right now turns out
that's just the thing we say but that's
not true i like how like after six
months she's like i'm gonna find that
nazism right like nine months it's there
i just gotta be in the back
in the member content i'm imagining like
she finally finished watching all the
videos and her eyes are like just like
deeply sunk and like black and her like
skin is pale and she weighs like a
hundred pounds like
i've watched it all no but i've i can
i'm imagining because when i was writing
my book on north korea and i was just
telling all my friends about all these
cool kim jong-il stories i heard and
after a while they're like okay i don't
care about north korea so she's like
we're talking to her friends or her
boyfriend whenever they're like i don't
care about this beanie guy can you
please talk about anything else ben
shapiro
the young church even reuben something
anything and she's like well i watched
eight hours of his videos today and i
just i can't stop thinking about one
thing he brought up and you you gotta
understand the great reset is real i'm
telling you yeah now she works for
rainforest now there's gonna be like a
romantic novel coming out about someone
who falls in love with you because they
watched all of your content and that
woman's name was owen schroer oh my gosh
dude she could probably do such a good
impression of you 50 50 gray beanies or
something yeah right
should we talk about the news yeah we
should all right here we go here we go
we got this story from cnn ooh cnn ron
de santa signal support for stripping
disney of special self-governing status
as feud escalates because apparently the
only republicans who actually do
anything are in florida yeah that's
weird so basically disney has this this
a special thing going back to 1967 a
state law that established the reedy
creek improvement district giving disney
the power to establish its own
government in central florida he
basically said you know what why should
we have companies that have this special
privilege right which is a smackdown
because
desantis said disney went too far
i think disney what did go too far
because after the backlash uh well let
me slow down disney refused to call out
the parental rights an education bill
which the left calls don't say gay which
makes no sense because that doesn't even
make sense um and so they refused to do
anything disney employees walked out
some of them got arrested for child sex
trafficking whole other story but around
the same time mind you and then disney
decided they were gonna be like oh okay
okay yeah we oppose that bill and we're
gonna see it defeated in the courts and
then desantis is all like yo
what does disney have to do with
the people passing legislation that's
gone too far now you got republicans
saying they're going to be going after
disney and stripping away their rights
and good
i'm loving it because these leftists
abigail disney actually she's the uh
gran grand niece
of uh uh of walt disney himself she's
the granddaughter of uh roy disney who's
co-founder
and she was saying like
these far-right groups are trying to
rule by minority and they're they're
saying insane things referencing chris
chris ruffo and all that but she says
it's i'm happy to see the right finally
going after the business sector that's
for so long propped them up or whatever
and i'm just i'm just sitting here
watching like
you know did you think disney propped
the write-up well
these companies are all woke that's why
i'm like what do you think's going on
yeah the the institutions are all woke
leftists critical race theory etc
the right has not been supported by cnn
i mean look let's just say starting in
2015. how about that but we know it goes
back further yeah i i think well i'm a
little bit torn because as an anarchist
i like the idea of a company being able
to have its own government within its
own jurisdiction but i am ecstatic
that if either the political parties and
hopefully both alienate from corporate
america which has historically been i
think to a large extent you have these
kind of chamber commerce mitt romney
republicans have been a thing in the
republican party especially after like
republicanism was defeated by fdr you
kind of had these you know weak
republicans who were kind of like you
know suburban shop owner
middle-of-the-road kind of types
and they kind of made apologies for
corporations just doing really
unconscionable things so the fact that
republicans at all are coming to
understand which democrats many
democrats for a long time understood
that corporations are not your friend
that if a corporation were a human being
that person would be a sociopath
and the more distance there is between
politics and corporate america the
healthier it is for everyone involved
including corporate america i think i
think corporations could also be likened
to the borg yeah
so you know i like to point out the borg
in star trek is like communist they're
this collective they just grow and
expand i think that's a better way to
view it because it is a it is a system
of governance the borg it operates in
but corporations are not too dissimilar
and that they absorb other companies
they grow expand they're authoritarian
and single-minded yeah profit is their
motive i i worked for disney as a temp
for their pocahontas premiere in the
park in central park and speaking of the
borg they had like a dress code you
couldn't have piercings you couldn't
have like dyed hair like there was this
very specific list of things about your
appearance that you had to have even
just working for that one day for them
where was it disney world or central
parks they had pocahontas the movie had
the premiere in the park was a thing
i like my age now i don't know all about
this it just seems so weird that any
corporation would would have its own
government on u.s soil that doesn't seem
right to me so it's weird isn't it yeah
it's very very strong it's it's similar
in anaheim with was it disneyland or
whatever i don't know where is what
world is in florida
yeah and uh so when the when people were
rioting down in anaheim over i think it
was a blm thing or something like that
and like the police came out
in force
more than i'd seen in most places and
it's because well now you're coming
after a major corporation in their
corporate profits so once the once the
once the riders and you know protesters
started getting close to this bridge
that brought them close to disneyland or
whatever the cops just went off they had
boken you know what a bokken is it's
like a wooden katana and they were on
horseback with boken what where where
the cops get those from i don't know
like with the mulan exhibit it was it
was it was a weird thing to see cops on
horseback with boken but it was also
kind of cool i'm like these are these
are like samurai warriors i guess it's
the weirdest thing to me i don't think i
don't know if they actually hit anybody
with them but that's what they're for
they're for
striking people i got a prediction i
think that this is going to go to the
courts or do whatever disney's going to
fight it for a while then they're going
to agree and be like okay whatever and
then they're going to start lobbying
other states and be like who wants
disney world and then california is
going to take it you don't think so i
mean the cost of moving that thing would
be insane
um i i think they i think it's i
disagree and i think it's more that they
have to publicly make a show fighting it
but then if they lose they could be like
well we did what we could yeah so a lot
of these corporations don't have the
spines they look like any person will
take as much space as you give them but
as soon as you you put your foot down
they're more than happy to you know kind
of roll over like a dog and you put on
something they make a really loud noise
and then rolling i want to i want to
make a point for mr mouse here you you
have this famous quote about police
uh what every cop is a criminal well no
a more a more specific quote that a lot
of people say
i don't know which one you mean about
killing kids oh there is no law so
obscene that the police would not be
willing to enforce it up to it including
the mass execution of innocent children
yes um i think there's something similar
for uh corporations oh for sure i think
it's fair to say that there is there is
no um
path to profit so obscene that a
corporation would not pursue it up to it
including supporting the the pedophilia
and grooming of your children well i
mean we see it in like like like mining
and you know in very poor countries and
uh like was it tropic um was it dole or
kita chiquita yeah chiquita banana
banana republic yeah i think yeah that's
where the term comes from i believe so
uh you know again i i think one of the
things that corporate media does in
dividing people to right and left
democrat republican is that if
conservatives or republicans hear a
leftist argument they dismiss it out of
hand but i think it will behoove them to
listen a little bit more to some of the
things that the wrong people are saying
because oftentimes there's a kernel
truth to them and one of them is that
corporate behavior especially
internationally is often completely
unconscionable well i think
i saw this with with the rise of trump
when i was in florida at his rallies
regular people told me they weren't
republicans i remember this one specific
moment i was in a flo i was at a florida
a fort lauderdale rally and i was
talking to a middle aged woman and she
was like i've never voted before i'm not
a republican so you know i'm just here
because trump's saying things that i
like and i think that's what the
republicans didn't like this insurgency
of regular people so trump brought this
populist wave in and now it's no
surprise there's popular support among
the conservatives on the right to go
after woke corporations because regular
people don't like their kids being
screwed with whereas previously the
establishment republicans were very much
like hey man the businesses you know
are hooking us up don't get in the way
similarly with democrats but you know
they do different things playing catch
back and forth trying to you know say
what they need to say to win now you've
got people who are like i don't care if
you're a corporation or a government if
you suck you suck well look at it this
way just to add to your point to agree
with your point when you think of
someone from kentucky you think of the
stereotypes think of the bad stereotypes
think the good stereotypes whatever you
think you're not thinking of mitch
mcconnell it's impossible to think of
kentuckians and then think that mitch
mcconnell is the guy in washington who
represents what kentucky means it's an
absurdity yeah really
michael oh a pizza arrived
this is courtesy of john schnatter's uh
papa john's michael screamed and stomped
his foot and said if you don't have my
pizza i'm not doing the show that's
right it's starting to smell good in
here look at me i'm shaming
first of all this was put in front of me
by some racist in the studio i thought
that it would be funny that's so crazy
not racist if you're not human oh my
gosh wow yeah because he's because he's
a leprechaun right right right
but uh but but also you can't be racist
against white people i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure i'm pretty sure youtube
allows that right irish people weren't
white until being white meant you had to
apologize for being white no he's
absolutely right there was arguments
including in america in the early 20th
century that regarded in some cases
irish people are as part of like the the
black uh population something
interesting you want to hear something
so uh where the the stereotype of the
drunken irishman comes from
is drunk and irish man let's be real bro
we're not gonna lie ireland yeah exactly
check this out
we're not gonna pretend yeah let's just
go with it you don't scare
when poor irish immigrants were
struggling or homeless they would
pretend to be drunk so that they would
get taken to police stations where they
would get a food to eat a place of sleep
yeah and british people actually have a
substantially higher rate of drinking
problems than irish people it's not only
well the british people have more of a
problem with it but they don't do it as
much but they're uh they do it more than
us russell in his book reading history
towards the united states talks about
this also because you had all these
super waspy factory owners you had all
the irish people came over they did
their hard work then they went home and
they ran drunk and these wasps who had
the protestant work ethic where you
thought working hard was inherently
moral and relaxing was somehow
inherently sinful and something to watch
out for they were flipping out they're
like look at these guys are low lifes
they're degenerate they're subhuman
they want to go out and get have a good
time but as a result of those drunken
immigrants a lot more people started
having less work hours having to pay for
overtime because wait a minute if those
low lifes are getting so why am i not
that's how it works you're saying the
labor movement wasn't a bunch of like
proud leftists raising their fist
there's a bunch of drunken irish people
[Applause]
who were talking about it i'm not
talking about even the labor movement
saying this preceded the labor movement
this was a one i'm kidding you're
telling me i just seven days a week i'm
supposed to be there what am i supposed
to drink
but he had i mean that guy you're
channeling i'm assuming your grandfather
has a great great grandfather he has a
point no it's true uh i studied guinness
the history of guinness basically the
dock workers would make the beer or
whoever would make the beer and then
they'd give all the good beer away but
the irish they didn't have any money so
they'd get scraped the bottom of the
barrels to drink make the beer out of
that goop and that turned into guinness
which is my favorite beer person oh
blair blair white is in the chat blair
she said what up damn tim pool's dad
will not stop talking
he's got a lot to say i hear he has a
book coming out too how strange speaking
of how's the book coming along um
oh sorry i caught you in the middle of a
spit of a feast
this is a live show we can talk later
he's got a job to do i just passed 150
pages it's probably going to be 280
maybe 300 so it should be done not long
i have one tough chapter left um and
then it'll be all smithsonian it's
called the white pill do you feel like
you're getting white-pilled as you write
it no uh because i'm writing about
atrocities that are being done to
millions of people including children uh
i as i've mentioned before i've been
crying a lot but this is the kind of
thing
where when people read it be like have i
never been told this yeah this is about
the questions
are some of these things too spicy to
give us an example or i'll give you one
example this is a very easy one so i'm
writing about the soviet union in the
1930s you had this big series of purges
right so you you killed the dad right
because whatever dubious reason then the
wife is arrested because she is a wife
of the enemy the people that was the law
and she can't even say i'm innocent
because you were married to him now that
kid has no parents overnight they're an
orphan they're beat up at school because
you're a kid of the enemy the people and
people who your family was friends with
couldn't take you in because why are you
taking in this daughter whose dad was a
spy supposed spy and now you had a rash
of all these kids killing themselves and
they're like what are we gonna do about
these kids killing themselves so this is
the kind of like logic that happened in
the soviet union and these atrocities
that
the fact that i'm like the only one
talking about this is really disturbing
to me and when you have the new york
times saying this isn't happening this
is all anti-russia propaganda did you
see i want to see this twitter thread
there's a twitter thread uh going viral
i i forget the guy's name so forgive me
but he talks about why
they why why the left is freaking out
over the parental rights and education
bill so much
now there's a meme where someone says
it's not rocket science guys they're
just evil and they want to do that aaron
mcintyre let's give him credit yeah but
but he's wrong and uh there's a great
threat about this that james lindsay had
retweeted and i forgive forgive me to
the the podcast host who posted it cause
i forget his name i don't know if you
guys want to try and look it up but uh
what he was saying is
this what's happening
um and i think he's saying it's
intentional his revolutionaries need to
sever the relationship between child and
parent yes and so what they do is they
first in secret will start explaining to
the children why they're evil and bad
and why they should feel guilt and shame
once they've sufficiently made these
kids
hate their own identity and their
parents identity they offer up
alternative identities you can now be
one of these oppressed minorities pick
and choose you can be anything it's all
a social construct then when the parents
finally find out and are shocked by
what's happening
the kids are already so deeply and
entrenched in the ideology
that the teachers can then say see we
told you they'd come at you they you you
could only trust us yeah and at a
certain age you want to be against your
parents because as a teenager you want
to be your own identity so it's very
useful to leverage that kind of a
natural social uh but so age group i
don't i don't know if i could go so far
as to say there's an intentional cabal
of you know people doing this but i can
say
that
whether whether it's a conspiracy or
just it's happening it is happening this
way
and the way uh this gentleman describes
it is it's because there's a lot of
teachers who are following a curriculum
that seems to be empathetic to children
who are experiencing some issues and so
they're they're going along with it but
i think the important point why is the
left so hell-bent on lying about what
this bill is calling it don't say gay
well the bill also
prevents teachers from talking about
heterosexual marriage and traditional
relationships why do they need to frame
it this way the one thing they're truly
threatened by
the bill does not prevent teachers from
talking to children about being gay it
prevents them from doing it in secret
they can't tell the kids don't talk to
your parents the teacher many of these
teachers are saying they're going to do
it anyway all right if you're an adult
and you want to have sexual
conversations with five to nine year
olds and you say don't tell your parents
i'm to go ahead and assume you're
grooming these kids 100 or worse what
else are you supposed to assume i mean
that's the most it's not being
uncharitable that's the most reasonable
possible assumption and you mentioned
that they want to sever children from
their parents and
it's very true it's debatable whether
there's a concerted effort but you see
this in media all the time the family
unit is consistently attacked and
basically every television program the
father is always a complete [ __ ] who
can't do anything right and that's
because if you want to go after any
structure you start by attacking the
authority and so it's been seared into
an entire generation of people if not
two or three generations on some level
that dad is stupid and not to be
respected and made fun of and i think
part of it is just a result of the fact
that a lot of artistic people who go
into hollywood don't have great
relationships with their fathers
generally speaking i think that's more
typical not always the case i think it's
a reaction of feminism because feminists
for a long time were claiming
proclaiming that you shouldn't show
women as being stupid but that only
leaves the guys yeah i think there's
truth in that too but even if you go
back to the honeymooners which i would
say is is before feminism had saturated
the culture as much the husband was
still sort of weak and stupid and very
lucky to have his wife yeah yeah but he
would always threaten a beat that's true
that's true right so they removed they
did soften these types of characters
with feminism but there is this
interesting trope of like dad being a
hapless fool
simpsons i absolutely have to shout out
futurama
american dad the white fun american debt
is dumb well no no in futurama they go
to the moon and it's a thousand years in
the future
and uh they're they're watching the
honeymooners and it's like one of these
days bang zoom straight to the moon
and then leela's like i didn't realize
21st 20th century astronauts were so fat
and then fry's like he's not an
astronaut and he was just using beating
his wife as a metaphor for uh he was
using space travel as a metaphor for
beating his wife
i'm wondering if in all this division of
family in the soviet union when they did
it were there kids that
basically had their beliefs shattered
and then reformed and then at some point
realized maybe even too late like what
have we done as the government turns on
them like are these people that are like
useful pawns are they turned on
eventually oh yeah i mean then stalin
turned on the secret police and then he
turned on the top of the military which
was a major problem world war ii because
all these military geniuses were killed
another thing that they taught in the
soviet union very famously was the story
of pablo marozov who was this little boy
whose dad was doing was like
hoarding grain and he turned his dad
into the authorities and his dad killed
him this is a completely made-up story
but he there were statues built to him
and like songs about him because you're
taught in school if your parents are
doing something wrong you have to inform
on them and if you're killed you
basically become a saint this is the
greatest thing you can do michael do you
watch anime god no you need to watch
attack on titan i i disagree with that
i've never heard the word need used more
incorrectly
and uh so there's a meme of like an ai
jordan peterson saying watch attack on
titan
and you know why amazing because he
wanted itunes gift
i don't actually expect you to watch it
so i'm just going to spoil the gist of
it for you it's already spoiled it's
anime yeah so the the first season
first you're gonna you're gonna love
this the first season oh yeah one more
thing i just gotta say the only cartoons
i watch are freedom tunes thank you so
much appreciated the first season is uh
there's this the last city it's
surrounded by three walls and there are
giant humanoid monsters called titans
that eat people yeah i've seen the
preview yeah yeah and they're invincible
what it's really about is that there was
a great nation that somehow came into
the power to become titans and use it to
conquer the world eventually the nation
crumbles i'm not going to spoil too much
and now in the future these people are
effectively in a prison to pay the sins
of their ancestors in the mainland where
some of these people are called aliens
still live the the now dominant country
says you're evil because of what your
ancestors did and so you're they're
forced to live on reservations and then
they're they're basically treated like
second-class citizens people say like
whenever they come into like a situation
with someone they're like yeah well you
you have
the evil blood in within you so there's
a scene where a kid turns his parents in
because they're trying to rebel against
the government because you know they
refused they believe in the greatness of
themselves and things like that there's
a whole bunch of themes that that talk
about a lot of what we're going through
with sins of the father
uh white privilege
gulags and all of that stuff and that's
what the show is really about and so at
first i was like i gotta be honest when
someone told me it's about people who
like use these ropes to fight giants i'm
like i really don't want to watch that
yeah and then when the robot jordan
peterson said you got to watch attack on
titan or you can do but you have to
watch it on right now watch attack on
titan embody the archetypal hero sit on
your couch so i watched it yeah and then
it's like
it's it's crazy how there's like one
scene where there's two little girls and
one little girl's mother was killed and
but she's the evil race and so then the
not eat like the perceivably you know
the the one girl she's like your people
are evil and your mother deserved to die
and she's like why my mother didn't do
anything to anybody and she's like
because of your blood and it's just
it's brutal man show's so cool and then
there's like people zipping around and
fighting giants so i guess that's a plus
but there's also like that reminds me of
a fantastic planet which is uh you know
a movie about like the giants calling
humans as pets and it's that it's a
parable for czech slovakia and the
soviet uh occupation oh wow
was that how they were treating the
checks because you would love to see a
movie ian because this is the most like
like uh psychedelic movie like it's made
by paper cut outs you've probably seen
the iconography what's your caller
fantastic fantastic planet thank you
there's no way you won't love this movie
oh wow and if what's really crazy is if
you watch a certain version it's dubbed
but the subtitles don't match the
dubbing they're slightly different
translations so you're watching it's a
complete uh it squeezes your head
completely interesting it's interesting
how stuff like that works in a cinema
like the idea that godzilla is actually
a metaphor for nuclear weapons yeah yeah
was it yeah oh yeah and it's and it's go
jira gojira well i'm sorry tim uncle
you know i was just doing it
in case you haven't heard i was just
doing an april fool's joke of course
it's go jira as a factoid
it is gojira but because what the
japanese people were saying gojira
americans thought it was an accent for
godzilla wasn't jackie gleason in the
first movie was he or orson wells it was
some major person was in the first movie
first godzilla yeah it is kind of crazy
there was a show where like the joke was
he was going to beat his wife and the
audience would laugh yeah
i'm going to beat my wife
used to smack women in the movies and
people would be like i love him that's
the best performance a lot less back
talk in those movies yeah it's very
cultural truth hey i wanted you brought
up uh april fools i wanted to give you a
little history yeah on april fool's day
well i'm just going to say whatever
you're about to say it's probably
contestants probably knows because no
one knows don't trust me did you look up
snopes no
i don't believe it
yeah it's quick i thought that april
fool's dates thought came from about
1582 as france changed from the julian
calendar to the gregorian calendar uh
april 1st was the first day of the year
in the julian calendar and then when
they changed it to january they started
making fun of you said probably making
fun of people that still lived under the
julian calendar as they're all now
gregorian so i and i mentioned that
before we started the show
i mentioned that before starting the
show my citation was an episode of the
simpsons so that's i i also wanna i'm
for everybody who's listening
put a one in the chat if you think that
michael malus will finish the whole
pizza by himself i'm not gonna fish no
pizza but is he lying is he lost the
question i'm not there's no way i'm
finishing this
hit the like button if you think he's
lying there you go
also if you think he's telling the truth
and send it yeah also hit the like
button and send a dollar to paypal at
michaelmouse.com if you think i'm lying
dude michael how is austin i gotta ask
you i gotta know i
i am so so so happy every day in austin
i can't even begin to tell you and i'll
give you a rundown of reasons why first
of all i didn't realize to what extent
living in i was just in l.a last weekend
signing hardcovers i didn't realize to
what extent living in new york i had
this background music of anxiety and
tension yeah and i don't have any of
that in austin second austin is such a
venn diagram of different scenes making
it happen and everyone is very collegial
like they all get together and you you
when you meet people you're friendly in
new york when i would go to an event or
meet someone i'd have to bite my tongue
like who is this person are they going
to be annoying are they going to smile
out to my face then go on twitter and
blast me there's none of that in austin
there's things i missed the restaurant
scene it's not what it could be austin
closes down early there's no like diners
so if it's like 1am you want to get a
bite you go to ihop which was a
situation but i am turning my house into
like this get-together space so that all
the people coming through can i throw
these little events everyone can meet
each other and hang out and it i did
only one so far and it's worked
absolutely swimmingly
i have a question do diners in new york
city take reservations no
oh
i don't get it so i had a tweet that
went viral on reddit the left was
attacking me because i said i went to a
diner and they sat someone before me so
i got mad and left and they were just
like tim poor doesn't know what
reservations are and then a diner and
then but the reason i asked us i was
like maybe maybe the people who are
sharing all of this live in new york and
like new york is so crowded that they
would take reservations at diners too
man they're just dumb yeah i guess so i
explained it i worked at like a nice
diner it wasn't a diner that's a thing
it was a french canadian restaurant that
served diner-ish but really high-end
food we definitely took reservations but
it wasn't a diner you know it wasn't
like you know you get your diner food
you're 7.95 there is a restaurant in new
york i don't know if it's survived
coveted called diner um but i they did
take reservations but obviously that one
you meant
yeah i've been to so i've never been to
a diner that took reservations it was
the weirdest thing to me when the left
was like tim poole's so dumb he doesn't
know what a reservation is and i was
like
bro we're in a diner like you walk in
and there's like one like haggard old
lady with a cigarette going wait you
want to sit
no should go sit anywhere you want honey
well no they were like there's a wait
there's a 20-minute win and then i was
like okay and then they sat actually two
groups before us and i was like okay i'm
leaving like i'm not and then i tweeted
about it kind of as like a half joke
because like you know i just tweet as to
be silly but also because i was making a
point about being a disagreeable person
on on petty petty [ __ ] as and the
point being that
uh
it helps you in business being
disagreeable especially on petty things
you don't be a dick to people but if
you're unwilling to compromise for small
things then you'll tend to get better
deals you and you have to establish your
own boundaries too because i'll give you
an example this this actually happened
i flew
to
la because i was being interviewed for
some hbo documentary uh which i'll get
it to it that's a future date and they
were dragging their feet about booking
my planes so i'm like i'll just do it
myself you guys can pay me back
i booked the flight i get back i do a
killer interview and they really liked
it great and they're like all right um
before you get reimbursed you need to
fill out this like w2 or w9 and i go
you have all the information you need
you have my paypal address and you have
the receipt you can choose to pay me
back or not that's your prerogative i'm
not doing one more thing
and they were like well we have to i'm
like you have i've i've said my pieces
on yes discussed they paid me but that's
the kind of thing where
that was me being very very petty but
it's amazing how companies will make you
jump through hoops
even when you're helping them and i'm
very big on really being obnoxious about
and drawing line ahead of time because
otherwise they'll just keep asking for
more and more no i totally agree yeah i
i why wouldn't they i yeah the machine
craves profit why wouldn't they leverage
everything leverages everything so you
go into a business meeting if if you go
in with a mentality of desperation and
need you've lost 100 but
if you genuinely need
well that's your position so you know
i've been position positions where i go
into a business meeting knowing like if
i don't get this deal i'm screwed and i
walk in and i'm like what do you have to
offer and they'll be like we're going to
pay you this much and i'll be like make
it a little bit more and they go okay
i'm like all right thank you very much
i've been in business meetings where i
didn't need anything from them and i
walk in they're like we want to pay you
you know 100 000 i'd be like give me
half a million and then go we can't
afford that i'll go well thank you for
your time yeah you know it's you've got
nothing for me yeah when you go into a
meeting or
interview or whatever you want to ask
them what what can you give me can you
give me what i need even if you you're
the one desperately in need don't let
them know that you you put them on the
defensive and you ask them if they can
give you the things that you need and
let me say one more thing kids if the
filthy hippie is telling you to walk in
the business meeting and say give me
give me give me you know it's coming
from a place of truth psychedelic
my favorite
one of my fav favorite bits of advice i
gave to somebody
is i uh they got a job offer at a
company i worked at is vice and um i
told my friend like hey i'm putting in a
good word for you i could use your help
tell them you want this job he said okay
he emails
he messaged me back saying hey i'm not
gonna take the job they're only offering
me 60k a year
and i said
uh well how much do you want and he was
like i don't know i don't really want
the job and i said okay would you do the
job for 80 and he goes no i said would
you do the job for 19. he was no like
would you do the job for 120 and he goes
well 120 yeah and i was like so that's
what that's your answer email back
there's no no in business it's just
terms and he was like you want me to
email back telling them to double their
offer and i was like you don't want the
job any what's your worst case scenario
you don't get a job you didn't want
right and he was like oh okay he emailed
him and they were like we appreciate
your response but we're unable to pay
you that much and he was like okay and
then i was like what was your worst case
scenario and he's like nothing right and
they came to me and they're like your
friend asked for a lot of money and i
was like yeah you didn't really want the
job no
but but in their heads your friend is
worth a lot of money right they're going
to reach out to me next time instead of
being now they're going to know what his
price is
exactly so it'll save everybody a lot of
time so here's what i love asking people
i probably i think i brought this up on
the show a year ago or so uh
michael
if you got a phone call tomorrow morning
from mcdonald's corporate hq and said
michael we want you to run the cash
register at our uh des plaines illinois
location off of you know 355 or whatever
i don't know what what would you say to
them
no
for you it might be
i i would be reticent or reluctant to
say wrong answer but
that's typically the wrong answer in
business there's i don't think there's
any amount of money i would do that for
because i meant i would it's not the
money that's the issue i'd have to
sacrifice my entire career or what i'm
working towards that's why i say for you
yeah but for the average person the
answer is how much yeah right give me
200 a year yeah 200. but for a lot of
people that's i mean they would they
would gladly do i was going to say less
i was going to be like tell mcdonald's
you want 100 grand to work the register
most people are going to be like yeah
but then you got to move
that's true you know and that's very
expensive not to have friends and it's
it's business is all just about the
terms and the leverage you're willing to
to make so
the more you're willing to sacrifice the
more leverage you have the more you win
so if you're like look buddy i'm willing
to sleep on a park bench and i got
nothing to lose you're paying me what i
want or you're not getting me they're
going to be like oh man i guess we have
to
some people have families or they go
into that i guess we really don't want
them
yeah fine whatever and then go sleep on
a bench i actually don't believe this
happened to me i had was working i had a
meeting with a celebrity when i was
doing my co-authoring stuff and we
really really hit it off um and
i you know i had my standard fee and
they came back with half of it and in
retrospect i have to appreciate that
that was their move it's like oh yeah
you're asking for x how about half x
what do they got to lose right i was
livid and i don't even remember if i
took that project or not or if i didn't
know i know i didn't know you know what
i do i don't respond to them oh yeah i
actually snapped at one of the biggest
radio comp like biggest production
companies and like distributors in the
world they i had this big business
meeting i'm in a room with like 10
people and i don't want to give away too
much information for the sake of their
privacy because they work with some
people people like very very famous
personalities they sent me a contract
with the most insane and ridiculous
terms i'd ever seen and i responded back
with this is the is this a joke please
if you'd like to do a deal with me come
back with a real contract and they said
this is normal in business you would
hire an attorney who would amend the
contract and i said if you think i'm
going to spend five grand to correct
your your [ __ ] it's not happening
and so i just said feel free never to
email me again because i'm not gonna
waste my time one second further yeah
that happened to me not that long also
where there's some congressman from
brooklyn i forget his name his chief of
staff just emailed me he's like oh we'd
love to have a congressman on your show
great i go how about like
one hour on monday we could talk about
his background because he had an
interesting background and they go oh
he'd only be available for 20 minutes
and how about on wednesday it's like i
have an hour-long show i didn't respond
it's just like you're pushing him onto
my show and then you want me to
restructure the whole show for you who
the hell are you you know but there's
there's something about
not being joe rogan i guess to use it
for lack of a better analogy where these
people think you're willing to take this
because we get we get hit up fairly
often from people who are like can i ask
you do you think it's that not being joe
rogan or the fact that they're so
oblivious to how podcasting works and
how the internet works that they really
don't think in terms of cma hits maybe
but i'm pretty sure if they reached out
to joe and joe was like i'd love to have
on the show they would say tell us how
you know where to jump and how high like
just let us know here's why i think
you're wrong because when i when the new
write came out in i believe 2019 i got
booked to do rogan and i got booked to
do reuben who was very big at the time
both of them obviously and i asked my
publisher if they had money for travel
which not they don't always do and
that's fair and they put told me in
writing this the head of publicity no
they can do skype
so this is 2019. and the idea that i got
it broken to promote this book and i'm
going to call him up hey joe we're doing
skype is so
removed from what is you and i would
regard as normal or saying that a lot of
times i have to wonder what planet these
people are on it's true but we've gotten
hit up by people who uh
work in a similar space and they'll be
like hey this celebrity this this
prominent personality can come on your
show but you'll have to pre-record or
move your schedule and i'm like
you guys work in the same industry and
you know what else they don't realize is
a lot of these people that are maybe big
names for people who read okay magazine
if that sort of thing you're not going
to get the big numbers having them on
the show because it's going to be
vanilla they're not going to say
anything interesting and it's going to
be like people tune in but you're not
going to have the traction exactly they
think because they get a bunch of views
on their platform which was provided for
them by someone else who built it that
you're lucky to have them on your show
to collaborate with them it's like well
but they're not interested let's let's
uh let's hard segway back to uh the
politics that we're talking about i
wanted to ask you michael about uh let's
talk about what's going on with russia
and ukraine obviously you were born in
ukraine uh-huh uh and
i guess now
yeah i'm just curious what your thoughts
are what's going on you know russia said
they were gonna shut off here's the big
news russia threatened to shut off gas
to europe unless they opened bank
accounts that would hold their currency
us dollars in euro which would then do
an exchange for rubles and april first
came and putin did nothing like
a whiny little [ __ ]
he
he failed to uphold his own threat
against these nations so i'm curious you
know your thoughts on what's happening
i've been asked this more than anyone
this is probably the question i get
asked a lot and like people blow it on
my phone um and i pride myself on trying
to have an interesting perspective or at
least say something uninteresting in an
interesting way and i got nothing on
russia ukraine for the very simple
reason that i don't understand putin's
endgame uh i don't understand how he
thought this was going to end up that i
can tell you that anyone who just says
he's stupid or he's crazy that just
means they don't know either they're
just using this kind of word to kind of
kind of do the work i just i just
assumed you knew that um the the spear
of destiny has been buried in
the holy land
um so putin going for the spear of
destiny i i raised like five grand for
uh ukrainian refugees my dad was
recently he had business in ukraine he
was on a train getting out of there and
he was sitting next to some kid and the
kid kept crying saying they're going to
kill my dad they're going to kill my dad
my i heard this through my sister and my
dad who i've never seen cry in my life
who was kind of which is a big surprise
looking me a
kind of an ass um and not a very nice
person just like myself for him to lose
it really says a lot which is why i was
comfortable raising all that money um
what is not in dispute is that millions
of people fled war understandably uh and
my concerns are also with the russian
population mind you like the fact that
someone's living in russia now they
can't use their phone or they can't use
some bank account just seems crazy to me
unless it's talked about yeah but look
at what russia is back on track
well yeah and the ruble has restored
value they turned mcdonald's they turned
the m like sideways to make it a b and
now it's called like uncle something no
this isn't it really yeah yeah yeah yeah
they they've repurposed
what joe biden has done
is he severed the ties between russia
and the west
these restaurants still exist right the
russian supply chain still exists so
putin basically is like going to
industry and saying get what you can
that's why putin threatened europe he
said you've got to open russian bank
accounts it it's forcing western nations
to open russian banks propping up their
financial industry or their financial
sector my
as you and i mentioned a little before
the show started i what they're doing is
an enormous attack on the value of the
dollar
whether by design or otherwise and
if i'm a businessman and i see what
happened with canada with the trucker
convoy and i see what's happening with
inflation here
and i see that my money is not going to
be safe in u.s or western banks i'm
going to put my money elsewhere to make
sure that money retains or increases in
value and that is a very dangerous
slippery slope we are going down whether
by design or otherwise well you heard
the the black rocker guy saying put your
seat belts on it's going to get real bad
inflation but i think we all knew
because one of the things that we all
talked about in like 20 early 2020 mid
2020 is you can't just shut down all
industry yeah and not have an economic
like massive consequence like that's not
a thing or else every so often we just
be like school teachers just not work
for three months a year so at some point
those chickens are gonna have to come
home to roost this is not in dispute no
one doubted that so you've got to you've
got to find places to put your dollars
what what does the average person do
right i mean if you're living paycheck
to paycheck it's going to be like
venezuela get your money and spend it
immediately on whatever you can i would
honestly i'm not going to this is going
to sound like a joke but i would put in
crypto i think crypto's gonna be a much
better store of value in the short term
let alone the long term i think than the
us i think crypto is what the world
economic forum is hoping for you think
so you think absolutely digital currency
no they no not their digital currency i
mean things like bitcoin or ethereum i
know yeah i know they're they're stoked
on it they're very excited for it
bitcoin will be their gold and they'll
use ethereum is on the is on the is
what's on the amazon web services right
aws i don't know is it theorem ethereum
is basically a company right so uh
bitcoin is decentralized that's
resilient but what uh
i think the the the the elite the the
world.com davos group types they're
they're betting on this you don't think
crypto is a better store of value than
the us dollar oh it absolutely is oh
that's all i'm saying yeah no when when
when klaus schwab and these
international corporations are betting
on bitcoin you bet along with them right
yeah you you here's here's here's what
people are doing to make money they they
look where nancy pelosi is investing and
they invest right along with her yeah
because she's got an inside track right
i i told this uh before i don't think i
don't know if you know this but i went
to davos and i think it was 2017. i have
friends who set up a peripheral event
outside of the world economic forum at
like the base of the mountain or
whatever in davos the whole city becomes
events
pop-ups and bars and crypto was the
theme everyone there was like crypto
crypto is everything so i bought i
bought a bunch of crypto and i'm very
happy that i did i think i think uh
these elites
they want digital currency
bitcoin's trackable they can they can
see everything you're doing you know and
uh so it's perfect for them
they they they can ban you they can shut
down your account they can ban addresses
if i've got cash i can pull out you know
a five dollar bill and hand it to ian in
exchange for a beanie or something but
if we're doing bitcoin my address can
get blocked on the network
if they control transactions so
the bitcoin uh let me clarify this
if they can get control of apps if they
can get control of financial
institutions there are companies that
facilitate bitcoin transactions sure
you'll always be able to have your like
rudimentary decentralized service and
you can find an open source way to
transfer bitcoin but for the average
person look you can hide you can put
stacks of cash under your mattress or
you can put it in bank of america you
put in bank of america the government
can can take your money from you so
that's what they want it gives them
substantially more control you'll be
less likely to be holding any kind of
cash you won't be
so no one's going to no one right now
no average person is going to open up a
coinbase account and an open source
third-party wallet because it's gonna be
too confusing for them they're not gonna
care if they are into crypto it's gonna
be because it was simplified by say
coinbase or gemini or something sure and
the government can easily seize all that
stuff so it gives them more control it's
like we saw when they tried to do that
thing where they were going to track
ultra all accounts that had 600 bucks or
more in transactions right yeah this is
the path forward for them that being
said despite all that
yeah i i i bought a bunch of crypto
recently but i also think that this is a
huge market incentive to provide wallets
that are as easy to use as coinbase
because once this becomes like for
example apple a couple of years ago made
it so that even apple couldn't get into
their own uh iphones because uh as a
because then they were like if we leave
a back door for law enforcement that's a
backdoor for hackers too it's got to be
open source yeah i agree with you so so
i think but don't you think the bitcoin
people know this
yes they're the kings of open source
stuff yeah we were looking at uh crypto
payment systems metamask is not open
source at the moment which is a little
disturbing and that means any company
can have the government go to them issue
a national security letter then you're
gone and you wouldn't know like that's
the problem with when the source isn't
open you don't know what their code is
doing it could be feeding data to the
fbi as we speak coinbase could be very
well and you wouldn't know
i'm sure they are i would be surprised
bitcoin is still
you know the bee's knees right
regardless of what bad people want to do
with it don't let that that stop you
from recognizing how powerful it is and
how it can greatly you know help people
but also recognize the risks
not telling anybody to buy anything keep
that in mind guys no financial advice
for me i'm just saying
don't you know do your own research and
figure out what makes sense for you in
my personal opinion for me i bought up
on what point can the cops institute
civil asset forfeiture if you like what
level of cash do you have to have on you
before they can just take it for granted
not a level of cash i think is even a
dollar it's just it's just a measure of
them deciding that it was used in the
drug transaction
and not only that but like let's be real
ian they can take your shirt off your
back and then lie about it
that's so brutal but i mean
legally they could take
my money and be like he's he thought he
was planning on spending it on something
illegal so he took or he got this money
because he sold drugs you see that story
about a woman a dog
sniffed her out she had a bunch of money
in a briefcase she had like what did she
have like a hundred grand or something
and then the cops were like smiling
saying like we took this money from a
woman and everyone was like i tweeted
this i was like so you're saying you
just rob some lady yeah and everybody
was like yo they said she didn't commit
any crimes they just took her money they
those are the only dogs you're allowed
to hate
dogs yeah
but can they take the money and say
we're just taking it because we think
you're going to commit it no no they
have to say that you did so this is how
asset forfeiture works and there's a lot
of movement right now in politics thank
god to reign this in uh for the first
time i think in the last year of the
year before more money was seized
through asset forfeiture than through
all burglaries combined so basically it
goes to this medieval concept where if i
kill you with a sword the sword is
guilty and the sword can be destroyed
this was like a thing so basically what
their point is well we're not going to
allow as part of the drug war people to
enrich themselves through drug uh um
dealing and so on and so forth so i go
to your house i've decided that you're a
drug dealer so on and so forth i seize
all of your assets your your boat your
house your your i seize your um uh uh
bank accounts and they become basically
the property the cops and this and then
you have to sue although you have not
gone through due process and been found
guilty to get that stuff back now it's
really hard to sue when all your money
is spent and all your assets have been
taken from you
okay so that is kind of the situation
and it's really un-american and
unconscionable and it's kind of
surprising how much it's under the rug
yeah really it's so disturbing very very
disturbing and i gotta tell you if
someone is a drug dealer as which
something i do not support to have like
every penny that they have just take it
from them overnight seems a bit much
when that's not done to murderers or
people who harm children yeah
non-violent drug offense man let's talk
about it this is the i think that jerry
nadler just has been pushing forth
legislation let's talk about it right
here from timcast.com house passes bill
to decriminalize marijuana federally and
it was the republicans who said no
democratic rep jerry nadler passed with
a vote uh his bill sponsored by uh
sponsored by nether passed with a vote
of 220 to 204 along party lines
republican reps tom mcclintock brian
mast and matt gates joined the democrats
voting in support of the bill democrat
reps henry quail equeller and chris
pappas voted against it i'm i i would
really love to hear from thomas massey
why he is not listed among these
republicans did he vote against this
this is why i don't trust this stuff
right
when you hear it's like democrats want
to make it so that you can have pot and
then you hear that
certain republicans like thomas massey
or margaret taylor green maybe not
margie taylor green he's more
conservative thomas massey is more
libertarian but i'm like where are the
more libertarian voices matt gates is
voting for it it makes me feel like it's
probably not exactly what it is i can
guess why someone would vote against
this as a republican first of all mass
just followed me on twitter so congrats
to him for voting for the drug
legalizations um i think it's a very
dangerous slippery slope if the federal
government starts taxing things
that could be what they're concerned
about because that's not a thing i bet
that's it yeah and it's proposed that
they're going to do a five percent i
think sales tax sales tax is a state
level so now you're going to have state
and a federal tax just for one product
that is what i think would be the big
concern and it's yes and to be honest
it's 483 pages which is another reason
it should be one page yeah marijuana is
here by leaving this is why i'm saying i
don't trust them and massey's good at
finding a thing in it that's like whoa
you're slipping this in i'm not voting
for this yeah he'll read it it's got
stuff like coming through puerto rico
well the other thing in the bill that i
saw is also it's retroactively um
letting people clear their records
that's why i want to wow
well donald trump as i stated should
have granted clemency and pardoned all
non-violent drug offenses that weren't
plea deal like they weren't plugged down
so
some people you know at first i was
saying like he should let all these
non-violent drug offenders go um some
people are like well what if they sold
the kids i'm like okay okay okay that
okay all right right there i'm not sure
right so not those people when they said
what if they did something violent but
took a plea deal
you're right
they should have a review process to go
through legitimate cases of someone who
was like charged with selling pot to
another adult or something and trump
should just get out of jail
can i just add one more thing if you're
someone who is on a grand jury and the
point of a grand jury is the d.a or
assistant d.a puts forth the evidence
and the grand jury says is there enough
evidence here to charge the person and
put them on trial our legal system it's
not your charge you have to get those
charges approved by a grand jury if
you're on a grand jury it is very easy
to convince those grand jurors not to
return charges on a drug charge and
there's nothing the district attorney
can do about it so this is your ability
if someone is a non-violent drug
uh salesmen or whatever to get that
person off and save a life especially if
they're young and poor i don't think uh
here's the challenge and this i think
this will be a good conversation for
with you michael
are there some drugs that should be
illegal
i can't think of any what about like
fentanyl
well no the problem with fentanyl is the
dosing right right you don't it's not
like someone is taking fentanyl saying i
want to kill myself they think they're
taking let's say five grams and they're
getting 50 or that five grams is and
then your heart can't take and you die
so fentanyl was sold at doses that
people knew and understood in hospitals
yeah this would be this would be
resolved overnight
so then well this is why i ask right
because then you have the issue of what
if some guy is arrested for selling
let's say he's got 10 000 doses of
fentanyl and
let's say they're not misnumbered or
whatever and he dishes them out
throughout a city this person should not
be in jail or you know what do you think
that this person is pfizer
right you just described pfizer you are
that's true that's absolutely correct
what about are you think there's any
drugs that shouldn't be regulated what
do you mean by i think all drugs should
be relegated by the market the same way
that for example if you're jewish and
you keep kosher it's very important for
you that you eat food that is in common
with kosher law otherwise it's like a
major major sin and people don't realize
this but every food in the supermarket
has a little letter k
and the k is not even strict enough so
the people who trust
the there's a you
that's the passover if you're really
strict you have to have a u not a k what
is this
the u is like a different kind of
licensing agency a rabbinical licensing
agency so what you would have is instead
of having it be the fda who is you know
largely corrupt and whatever you would
have just like right now at whole foods
you'll have fair trade where you'll stay
up i was on the plane just now and the
pretzels on the back said woman owned so
if that's something matters to you you
can look for that label i mean the
pretzels would not shut up and they were
really annoying but the funny thing
about that is when it's like woman-owned
is that if you were a sexist you could
choose to discriminate against these
businesses whereas like if it's well no
the president could be like well i want
more women cooking women cooking they
cost 80
they cost 80 as much as the mail on
pretzels uh michael how how could there
be a wage gap if there's no way to even
define what a woman is
that's a great point
who's making wages
so follow up on the question about
regulation um what you said that the
thing about i feel like jen saki yeah
[Applause]
secretary you said that the uh the
fentanyl was about the dosing the dosing
so if people were just like i don't
there's no regulation on it and the
market dictates and he's like well he's
addicted to it so i can give him as much
as i want because the market's dictating
the guy's pocketbook is dictating what
he wants but it's a drug addiction sure
but what i'm saying is the problem with
fentanyl there's two issues or any
addictive drug it's the addiction but
also the oding and dying right and
that's the thing that's the first thing
to resolve and people not knowing dosing
so the more information that's out there
so people can make informed choices the
less people are going to be dying what
if it was regulated like like there's
there's a drug store that's got all of
the drugs all of them and you could
choose to do whatever you know but the
store couldn't give you an overdose
like you'd walk in and say i only buy
one dose at a time no like let's well
yeah well like aspirin imagine like that
what like you only buy one tablet at a
time no i well
what i mean to say is there's probably
different degrees to which it could be
regulated i'm not saying you know
necessarily you walk in and they say you
can only get one well they have that
this we don't have to guess about that
because we have that now uh tanning
salons you can only tan for x amount of
minutes so what they go do is they just
hit six tanning salons yeah and they
also have right now there's a workaround
for addicts where they go uh
prescription shopping so i'll have four
doctors give me prescriptions and then
i'll get them all filled so addicts the
thing that people need to appreciate is
addicts are really really good at
resolving their addiction and getting
workarounds they're gonna cause their
entire identity and their entire
worldview is about getting that drug so
to to pretend that they're gonna be
playing by the rules as opposed to we
have to realize what we're dealing with
and and and kind of work to mitigate so
let's let's say the regulation is that
the the fentanyl for instance if it's
being sold by a private legal entity it
has the doses have to be measured
perfectly and isolated at single doses
yeah sure i think they would love that
yeah so so the reason i brought this up
is like if the problem is dosing well
street doses can be all over the place
but if there is a a formalized process
that the government's like hey if you're
selling these things you have to use
like a specific machine that guarantees
the dosage so that you can't give
someone the wrong dose but that's also
right now in california like if you go
to like dispensaries they can only be
like 20 milligrams tops so it's it's got
this weird kind of situation where
no but i mean like
you'll you'll get a pill pack right like
you will for you know tylenol or
whatever and it's just like this is 25
milligrams of drug this is 25 milligrams
you're not getting 75 26 for right
exactly it's it's a you know but that's
what the market would have there's no
other there's no like it's not like you
go to buy vodka and one bottle of
absolute's going to be 80 proof the
other one's 10 proof they're all going
to be consistent but that you you can go
and get you know it's it's right the
market does it yeah it's a fraud issue
but you needed a prescription would you
need a prescription for the fentanyl
then and the people that can't get the
person i think that's the point i think
the point is you already can get
prescriptions for this stuff we're
saying prescription lists yeah personal
choice to go and buy whatever you want i
feel like they would just buy the 30 the
30 doses and take two or three at a time
and stuff or get someone to buy
you're saying it sounds like you don't
even need regulation in that capacity
because
why is the phone going
i suppose the bigger threat is that
they're going to be shorting you they're
going to tell you it's a dose when it's
a half dose to save money yeah they're
going to be like oh yeah yeah this is 20
milligrams well that's what you have
that's when you have branding because
then it becomes oh that stuff's weak
this is the good stuff same thing
without any other product
yeah and then uh like you know the thing
with potato chips like you buy the bag
potato chips is half air that's so
annoying but you know why that is right
it's not like they do it on purpose they
do do it on purpose dude i got it i
don't know that doesn't settle that much
i got an iced latte at starbucks it was
like 90 percent ice i got i sipped it i
drank it and it was gone and it was
absolutely nice cup of ice oh yeah it
wasn't intentional they filled the whole
cup with ice and then put the shot in
the milkshake the ice with a little bit
well to be fair shrink flation is
through the roof these days yeah you
know uh it's really funny someone people
people are posting these videos of like
boxes of cereal
a week later and it's like they're just
visibly smaller but the funnier thing is
when the boxes stay the same size
and then you see the ounces on the
bottom yeah goes down i'm concerned
about fentanyl i feel like it's next
level like heroin was dangerous but
fentanyl
it's russia it's like like crazy it's
gonna be that these guys ten times
stronger drug after fact
and we're gonna be having the same
discussion but it's like you can only
take one hundredth of a percent of what
you could take have you ever had taken
opiates
one time yeah have you michael had
opiates yes uh sheamus no uh i would
describe it as a nightmarish drug
nightmare i stretched on it and it
became useful i was when i had a kidney
stone i was given percocets and it was
a feeling so good it's indescribable
exactly yeah and that terrified me oh
yeah goodbye i was like wow i know
exactly why people get addicted to this
stuff it it felt like
it's hard to explain it feels like all
your joints have become removed like if
your body was made out of like hinges
like they get all unhinged so it's like
all your body's just i see why it felt
like it's floating and yoga yeah yeah
from i think that was all kind of
combined in the early years i would
describe it as like
it felt like a a
an energy of goodness emitting from
every part of my body are you big tim
cass sponsored by no no
i'm literally saying it's terrifying for
that reason yeah and so you know what i
did even though more yeah
you know
tossed them out wow you could have sold
those
or give it to children suppositories
yeah no no i i threw it i i i basically
tossed it into like a like i should push
it into i put on my windows so i threw
in my cat's water and i was like but
then eventually i just was like i don't
want these things man because uh uh
i got a power of pleasure
well it's it it it it was it's it was
scary i'm like i completely understand
why people can get addicted to this
stuff because it just feels so good and
you think what's one more time to make
it feel and it's that second time when
things just and then comes it doesn't
feel good the second time it doesn't
feel as good yeah chasing the dragon
it's it's like the addiction starts to
kick yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
every corned beef hash
that's him hold on you've never had no
food
don't assume delicious well like the
first bite is really good the second
bite is okay the third bite is in the
fourth bite you're like i'm done that's
like circus peanuts yeah eat one you're
like this is great the second one is
like please kill me in my family
if we were gonna use opiates as a
species that's how we should use them
you take one bite and that's it you cut
yourself off after that if you can you
know leave it to the to the addictive
human to make that decision
drugs are bad okay
i don't know the word drug is very weird
what is a drug anyway this is a suitcase
term it's a non-food that you ingest
that doesn't like in your chemistry it's
like the word conspiracy like as soon as
you hear it you know it's bad but it's
like it's applied to things correctly
and incorrectly caffeine's a drug yeah
that's right it's psychoactive but no
one's ever like lectured me about how
caffeine opened their mind you know
like hey man you gotta try it you're
gonna be like a different person not
true people often talk about how if they
don't have their coffee they can't think
they'll talk about how their coffee
makes them better but they won't be like
i'm enlightened because i had caffeine
they're not gonna say it they're not
gonna say i took a caffeine pill and i
met the machine elves yeah yeah yeah
michael i want to talk to you about the
machine house okay check this out here's
what i was thinking we talked about this
last week
i was thinking that you know the brain
naturally produces dmt
okay and so i want am i in rogan
yeah yeah i was well aren't you writing
that book on the machine no
so uh here's what i was thinking maybe
if we had some opiates we would be able
to
what i was thinking was
let's say uh i'm going to give you a
wild bunch of ideas that probably make
no sense but it's fun so multiverse
theory yes every possible permutation of
existence can exist or whatever so i'm i
was thinking about that and then i was
like if the multiverse is real and it's
infinite then there is a batman universe
and each one of these dc universes could
actually exist so we're not actually
imagining and making things up we're
just seeing into the multiverse we're
seeing a vision into the ether i started
thinking about that i'm like if people
naturally produce dmt in their brains
what if there's a connection line a very
very faint one but some people who are
very creative and talented have a
stronger line than those who don't the
people who are npcs have had their their
connection severed that's why when they
take dmt they blast off and it just like
opens up the portal and they see
everything and then it closes you see
what i'm saying yeah but i i i i it's a
little bit wrong from my understanding
we talked about this when i was on
that's what i said it's a bunch of crazy
ideas that probably make no sense it
makes perfect sense i just think it's
incorrect oh it's very coherent i i we
talked about this when i was on with
alex which is the idea that in the same
way that um a drawing of you or you
elected a drawing of you is you in 2d
and this is 3d tim and the elves live in
4d right so we're 3d projections of 4d
beings the point being that in the same
way that i could draw batman and he
exists in the drawing but batman doesn't
exist in 3d here in this earth a lot of
people that we see around us in 3d don't
exist in 4d so they are in fact
background characters who do not have a
higher eye being well so the machine
elves tell you secrets
okay do they i i wouldn't know
did they tell you anything well that's
what alex jones says yes so alex says
yeah so that's kind of my idea that it's
that you're you're getting a connection
to them that right they're explaining
things to you and sharing ideas and
information and so those with more
natural dmt in their system
might have a stronger connection to
hearing the whispers and the muse and
the and the secrets well the other point
that apparently there's a big
distinction between people who take dmt
and just see kind of shapes and colors
and those who actually communicate with
these entities um and i don't know what
what causes this divide uh between the
two groups maybe ian has some science i
don't know my experience with dmt is
still really limited um i'm interested
in changing that at some point so you
said that some people don't exist in
four dimensions correct so they're npcs
yes that's scary thought why is it scary
it's just fact what i'm thinking is i
just mean that there are some people out
there that you know aren't but that's
not the same does that explain a lot it
certainly does you know yeah that's what
i was saying that's what i said earlier
that you know for me personally i kind
of feel like i have a soul i feel like
there's a greater power out there and
some people don't maybe they literally
don't have souls right i was just
thinking it might be that calcification
of a pineal gland has something to do
with it that if you're calcified in your
block you're still seeing the shapes and
patterns but you're not seeing it clear
enough to notice that it's uh
sentient maybe even i don't know if the
sentience the right word but it's not
alive i wouldn't call it alive but uh
intelligent is that a fair word to
describe this field this force god is it
god in the image of man and that's why
we think they're elves because we're
getting this undulating fourth
dimensional movement of in and out like
like what is tightness and expansion
yeah what if what if it's not
necessarily that some people exist in
four dimensions but that some people are
ascending you know what i mean that
that's a good i i my understanding is
that this is the descending that we're
uh same way that a drawing is like a
lowering and a projection into 2d like
if i drew myself that this life or
whatever we want to call this plane is a
projection of 4d which is much more
infinite so we're like so we're like
playing a video game
kinda so
we we are all fourth dimensional beings
who decided to not all of us no no i
mean like us here because we're all
special people are we even this one yeah
believe it or not despite the lucky
charms if the theory follows suit
this is what happens when sheamus smokes
dmt first of all first of all no one
ever drank coffee and had this
conversation i just want to flag that
thank you know coffee is actually
attributed with ending the uh or or
starting the enlightenment kicking the
enlightenment age of enlightenment off
they would sit around stop those times
exactly
no no there's a guy who makes like
old-timey recipes and he made one about
like the first types of coffee and he
talked about like they would have these
coffee bars and all the people go there
to be intellectuals oh yeah and so what
was up into that point was beer you know
the water was dangerous to drink so
people drink beer and then eventually
they just kicked in the cof coffee
became because of probably colonization
and they were able to import started and
they're all tweaking and talking to all
hours so they're flapping their gums
here's what you know i suppose i was the
first tim cast yeah exactly i suppose
logic doesn't matter when you're talking
about multi-dimensional theory i
disagree i think it matters a lot well
then here's my question uh what is the
logic behind why some humans would be
semi-fourth dimensional why would a
fourth dimensional being
come down to the third dimensional plane
for entertainment oh that's a good
question right my that's i don't know
that's a great i think that the body is
an anchor this body is an anchor and
that that if you're if you're clouded
and you're you're calcified that you're
you're not in control of the of the
field around you like your your red
blood cells have iron which are magnetic
and you can not maybe not control the
magnetic field around you but
interact with it interface with it uh if
you're if you're dolled to that ability
because you know you're clouded then you
it might seem like you don't have a soul
but i think people go in and out of
either having a soul or not having one
depending on if you're calcified or not
and maybe it's not just calcified i
don't think people appreciate how much
wisdom it is and what ian says and the
more you watch the show and the more you
listen to him the more like suss it out
this guy knows what he's talking about
but what i just said that's not april
fool's
i just thought
i was like
i just i want to imagine
that um we have a third dimensional
plane let's put it in like a perspective
here's the threshold of the dimensional
barrier we're down here milling about
like little people all talking shaking
hands and watching and observing then
you move up into the fourth dimensional
plane and you can see there's like
tethers coming out of the people into
the fourth dimension from that
perspective it looks like each
individual person has some fourth
dimensional presence what if when you
move up to an even higher state you can
see that all of those lines come out are
connected to the hands of one being and
get this
what the people actually are like
sensory antennas that are just
dipped into the water to
collect information and then come back
part of one being but the elves are kind
of like paper dolls
so like paper dolls is basically you can
one sense it's one being it's another
sense it's in the but you can see one
end of the other so they kind of meld
into each other so is it the kind of
thing where also if you touch your hands
yeah i'm agreeing with you if you touch
your hands together you feel your left
hand with your right hand you can feel
it with your right hand you can feel
your right hand with your left hand you
have both feelings at the same time but
in reality i can only feel what ian
feels and tim can only feel what tim
feels but in the fourth dimension
there's a being that feels both yes yes
yes correct
whoa so this is the argument or is this
what would people report on dmt or is
that no we're just that's what people
report this and the thing is that it
it's very confusing not confusing but
there's just a lot of questions about
why this substance would have such
extreme effects
on people just from evolutionary
perspective how does that idea why those
effects be the same for everybody how
does that idea uh uh
jive with your idea on religion and god
i would say it's probably demonic i
don't know i don't have an explanation
but if my my first guess would be it
could be a demonic thing
it could also literally just be
hallucinations people are having i don't
know like this idea that um we are all
one with with with god and that he can
he like you know he can feel what we
feel he knows what we what we do and why
we do it well we're created in his image
and likeness and he does know everything
so could it be that oh yeah well what
number am i thinking of
let's roll the dice i didn't say i don't
know
92. the point was that you got it dude
how freaky would it be if i told you i
was like
the number was pie the idea ian is
saying is that he can feel things i can
feel things but then a higher power can
feel what both of us are feeling yeah
yeah that's i i would imagine that would
be possible here is something god could
here's something else that's really kind
of interesting there's something what's
i forget the term
for too long man i'm sure he knows the
term for this i don't know the term when
two people break the veil together and
they meet on the other side there's a
term for that oh wow
i need to know that's crazy is the word
sympathetic no there's a word there's a
term i forget what it is shared
hallucinations and there was a i watched
a crazy video from vice where this guy
said that he his his uh he went he did
he did dmt and he met a purple woman i
think we talked about this last time no
this is not familiar he met a purple
woman
and she talked to him about his friend
and she was like he used to come by here
all the time and he was like whoa and
they talked and then he came back when
he came back down he went to his friend
and shared it they shared information
that they hadn't previously exchanged
with each other yeah and a lot of other
people report that when they meet the
elves sometimes they always like what
are you doing here like how did you get
here like they're surprised
i feel like um michael from the
archangel from the bible and his friends
would take hallucinogens together and
have shared hallucinations and that was
god talking through them and michael
i'm curious what is the history of the
article the old testament real quick i
just want to point out i want to point
out one thing ian often just
makes up these like weird religious
connections yeah like angels doing dna
i'm very i don't know where that comes
from i'm very literal and realistic like
i'm very into like common sense and
realism so i'm trying to make a
realistic story about ancient history
that seems kind of almost magical
but i think you're trying to look at too
much through the lens of psychedelics
because i mean you're discounting the
possibility for there to be legitimate
supernatural experiences and also you're
discounting that if they aren't
legitimately supernatural that maybe
somebody made it up
but i i think you project psychedelic
experience onto basically everything
that doesn't fit within the ordinary
confines of what we see in everyday life
i'll be honest i have been since i i
started getting into terence mckenna and
the stone tape theory the idea that
hominids at some point started eating
psilocybin and gaining consciousness and
awareness that that has really turned me
on to like looking at the history
through that lens now a lot of times and
like when they say they saw jesus
walking on water like yo i took acid i
know what that what what hallucinations
are and when you see people like people
on acid all hallucinate the exact same
person doing the exact same thing at the
exact same michael brought up is that
people can break through and have the
same experience on dmt together large
groups of people i mean people
hallucinate but generally when a group
of people hallucinate they don't
hallucinate the exact same thing but you
could uh on to play devil's advocate
haha yeah there's also the ability of
when a bunch of people are all on
psychedelics the power of persuasion
becomes through the roof so if one
person's like oh look i see that
everyone else will start to see it
because their brain will feel them
charles
but don't also don't you think if dmt's
reuse it and i'm not just talking about
biblically but in any scriptural text
from any religion don't you think they
would mention psychedelics because we
know that psychedelics are part of a lot
of pagan religions and they discuss it
so if they were part of these other
religions and that's how the texts were
inspired why wouldn't that be discussed
i think i think you have to read a lot
into it to come away with that well
because on the other hand we don't know
what mana is we don't know anything
about it manna from yeah manna from
heaven is that what it was it was like
uh
we don't know they literally said they
ate man it came from heaven okay what is
it there's no description of it maybe
rain water mixed with the plants what do
you think it is boiled famous um it was
always this charm well it's like bread
right
it was always better for the irish
is it potatoes isn't that it well it was
it was always described to me as um
almost being bread like yeah though i'm
i'm far from being honest right here it
was food that was given to them as
sustenance not necessarily something to
like produce
experience no my understanding like in
juice school they taught us this that
basically they found that it like
spontaneously appeared overnight so it
wasn't absolutely something magical
supernatural you would love ben stewart
if you could also talk to him i think i
want to mention this i think the big
difference is if you're looking at
psychedelics i think someone who
believed that they had a supernatural
ability would say it's something found
in the natural world that leads the
supernatural experience whereas man is
the exact opposite it's something that
appeared supernaturally but gave them
the natural experience we had a really
good idea for a bit on cast castle where
in the background
what's that our vlog oh okay yeah yeah
one of the bits is that while stuff is
happening in the background you'll see
sheamus interacting with potatoes this
is why does it have to go hold on hold
on i'll make this point can i
finish the joke sheamus racist one of
the jokes was that like ian will be
talking to someone about something send
me you know just inane and then in the
background you see a pizza delivery guy
like handing the pizza to sheamus and he
pulls out a potato and hands it to the
pizza guy who then pulls out two smaller
potatoes and hence changes or he opens
the pizza box and his potatoes is the
topping
would it be hysterical if like i talked
about potatoes the way like ian will
bring up psychedelics i'm like no dude i
think they ate potatoes i think they ate
potatoes and that's why they saw it
happen
the potatoes has eyes you have to try
think about it why exactly because you
can see and they have roots it grounds
you i think that when the authorities
were writing the bible that they were
like if they take psychedelics they're
going to overthrow reality because
that's what it makes you do
helps people i i i caught that lydia
hold on here there's two things first of
all
secular or religious there are no
scriptural scholars who believe that the
bible is written by group authorities of
authorities they they understand that
these texts were not just compiled by
one group trying to tell a story but
also
um
if you're saying the authorities were
writing the bible that's right what you
said
so scriptural scholars
including the atheistic ones don't hold
the view that like a group of people got
together and said let's write the bible
and make this story oh no that's correct
yeah yeah yeah what about the council
that's where they sat down
in and out exactly and so
ian i i think part my question is or i
guess my point to you saying
because your question or your point here
seems to conflict with the other point
you made because you're saying they got
together they wrote the bible to have a
specific message and they didn't want us
to use psychedelics but your earlier
claim was it actually happened but these
people were just using psychedelics and
writing it from their perspective oh no
that or so it didn't actually happen but
this was a drug trip i think that the
writers like john the people that saw
jesus walk in were tripping but then
when the council of nicaea got together
they were like that stuff's too
dangerous for society to do right now we
need control of this let's not talk
about the psychedelic stuff so the
problem i have with that is the people
who brought the various scriptures that
they had in their possession to the
council of nicaea were really persecuted
in order to have them so some of them
had their eyes gouged out some people
were were killed for having these
scriptures because they're being
persecuted for their beliefs and i don't
think a text could mean that much to you
for you to get together with a group of
people and say you know what let's just
mess with this and have it say whatever
we want and remove the importance
that i i see no uh logical basis for
saying people were tripping when they
witnessed something well they said that
they saw jesus walking on water so what
what could you possibly give a logical i
mean
how that could happen my point is in you
you have you have you you have a bias
where you're like they must have been
tripping when okay no not must okay
you're right they don't want to say they
must maybe they were like all sick but
they used to get together and drink wine
because like the elysium you know
okay
my point is
you take every like you you have a frame
of mind
people are people are fairly familiar
with your frame of mind and you're like
i think it was tripping but there's
literally infinite number of
explanations for why someone could
hallucinate you know and also that
laughing disease that they had for a
while that was ergot a lot of stuff
comes from ergot which is a fungus that
grows on rye that makes people trip out
but it's also very harsh on your stomach
and they would drink it with wine but i
think ian the problem with that is when
you look at literally any historic
document we have you can make the same
argument even if it's describing
something which seems perfectly natural
well this person could have just been
hallucinating because they were on drugs
we don't know that they're describing
this properly yeah i don't want to come
out and say it happened like yeah that's
i i think you actually have a specific
you have to have a specific
i think you have to have a specific
reason besides saying this text is
difficult to believe to make the case
that the people who wrote it were this
is the burning bush i've heard that it
was the acacia plant which if you burn
it and breathe it in you start to have
psychoactive hallucinations and then
moses was sitting by a bush to start
talking to him and then he started
hearing god like you know i've heard god
at burning man i took a bunch of
mushrooms for a week and you start to
hear the vibration make sentient sound
it's i don't know where it's coming from
or what but it is a real thing and i was
on psychoactives at the time
so that what's
my point is
whether you have a suit obviously i have
a supernatural worldview i believe it
was god but
i think even if you don't believe it was
god you can have explanations aside from
this must have been could be moses is
lying or covering yeah no it's crazy it
didn't happen exactly i mean if it it it
could be it really happened or it could
be it didn't happen or someone made up
about moses to make it sound smart
exactly exactly well because we know
historically that people will make
stories up and so if you don't believe
these stories are true because you don't
think what's described could possibly
have happened there are so many other
explanations besides they were on drugs
they were doing so
i found some stuff on manna okay no no
no you guys need to have your long
religious let me read this about mana
really quick it's from exodus 16 14 when
the dew evaporated a flaky substance is
fine as frost blanketed the ground okay
so they're talking about like would you
put alcohol they're talking about that's
how you make dmt you like you you
extract the white powdery
exodus substances 31 the israelites
called the food mana it was white like
coriander seed and it tasted like honey
so it's like a white powder and that
sounds like a drug
you can't live on dmt the whole point is
nana was giving them sustenance in the
desert so even if what you're saying is
true they'd all be dead or it could have
been nutritious like ergot grows on rye
so they could have been eating rye that
was infected but they wouldn't say
whatever they were yeah all right so
let's uh let's move forward i'm just
curious you know your thoughts michael
uh i think we should do an entire tim
cast about mana
with dmt
what do you think happens when you die
what does that do with dmt well like
is if if we are meat puppets in the
third dimension sure when you die do we
just like wake up in the fourth
dimension as machine elves or something
or um i
excuse me one of the things that they
beat into us in juice school
and this is something that i very much
do prefer the jewish perspective to the
christian perspective is i've used this
story before is let's suppose you go to
this banquet and the table's just
overflowing with food and there's every
kind of fruit you can imagine and the
wines flowing and you got a turkey here
and you got a steak here and hams and
everything and it's just like you
couldn't even begin to imagine this kind
of banquet and then you go to the chef
you go oh what's for dessert like how
offensive that is so in the jewish
perspective to be like focusing on the
afterlife when god has given you this
amazing gift of life and how wondrous it
is and how he wants you to be happy and
achieve and just thrive and to just be
looking toward dessert is really like
spitting in his face i once i once had a
very christian friend of mine tell me
that she couldn't wait until she died
that when i'm not random
and he asked her he goes what's wrong
with saying you know i like i love life
everything's great but man i can't wait
to die and find out what's going on she
goes that's the problem she's like what
do you mean you can't wait to die like
she's like you said it unintentionally
and i'm not saying sheamus yeah but this
is a big concern because
life is not a dress rehearsal and i
think if you are a believer god put you
here for a reason and to just think that
this is just kind of you know the
warm-up act can have some very dangerous
consequences i think so i think a simple
way to look at it for secular
individuals maybe is like a sorting
algorithm
well when they say heaven and hell you
don't even have to look at it like
damnation or you know salvation or
whatever it's just like a sorting
algorithm some people go here some
people go there i think it's an
interesting point i would argue and you
acknowledge this that you don't think
this is the case for all religious
people i would say that
you should of course be very grateful
for your life i mean a belief in the
afterlife should not prevent you from
saying like this is just an unbelievable
gift in general and eternal life as as
we believe is catholics is very much a
part of that and a part of it is there
gonna be a butt huh there's a butt
coming there's a well i would say what i
disagree with is that a belief in an
afterlife necessitates a rejection of
gratitude for this life yeah we actually
talked last night about some people that
are just living for the now and take
take take they're not it used to be that
like hey do good time because when you
die if you didn't do good in this life
you're going to be punished so people
would
they wouldn't overthrow and burn things
down these people these i don't call
them godless but if it's just all about
now with nothing to worship i think we
would agree on this that you have to be
grateful for and appreciate life but you
have to be willing to sacrifice it if
there's a necessary cause like you'd
have to be willing to fight for like for
your family if someone's trying to kill
your family you it wouldn't be right to
run away let me simplify my family let
me let me see
if you believe there is something beyond
you
then you would recognize the other
person's individual rights and liberties
so for me that's kind of my world view
like why would i respect someone else's
life liberty the pursuit of happiness is
because i want them to respect mine if
you don't think anyone else exists or
matters you'll be solely egotistical and
and strive for power and personal gain
at any cost are there other sects of
judaism that do believe in an afterlife
in a more overt sense they all believe
in an afterlife to some extent but they
don't focus on it anywhere near as much
um and i one of the versions i've heard
is that everyone goes to hell and your
sins are burnt off and if you're really
bad you're burnt to a crisp then
everyone goes to heaven and there's
levels of heaven but there's very little
focus on the afterlife in in judaism
like interesting old testament is an
energy field that it's getting like
coursed through the earth's core you're
sensing that hellish fire and then it's
courses through the galactic core and
you burn with fiery rage and then you're
let off into the universe
i would not say it's an exact equivalent
but that's interesting because that is
sort of similar to the idea of purgatory
though we don't believe everyone goes
there we believe some people do go to
hell it's it's like if you went into the
forest you got covered in those little
brambles all over you those spiky little
things and then they're like you're like
i can't get them off so someone just
takes a flamethrower and just burns you
until they all get roasted and then
you're like thank you
but yeah and i guess the difference is
exactly like that yeah right i guess
yeah literally that difference is that's
something that's probably better
by elon's building
i i guess i can't speak for the talmud
but i know like the progression that
catholics describe as something that it
um it purges you if you your sin but it
like it doesn't leave you less than you
were
which i would imagine is what you guys
are also arguing no that makes you
better because it's getting rid of the
like what is it like like a giant
like a soul
you know they say resistance is
necessary for growth i wonder if your
soul experiences heavily heavy
resistance after death in order for it
to be purified what if uh and the
resistance is a form of heat
we are not projections of fourth
dimensional beings fourth dimensional
beings are just controlling avatars and
so like when we die we're nothing we
just
and the fourth dimensional being was
like those cool those michael bros but
that's right but that's like like if you
do a drawing of yourself and have a
comic stripper tim you know and ian and
go in the store blah blah and then you
wrap up the comic strip tim and ian are
still existing well yeah but what i mean
is like
you michael being controlled by a fourth
dimensional being not control their
projection but what i'm saying is like
when i play a video game sure like the
character on the screen is a projection
of my will in the game but when the
character gets mutilated and erased
i just get up and i'm like bye and the
character's gone so for you or me in
this world once we're done there's gonna
be like some some fat fourth dimensional
dude in his basement going like guys i
go oh that was cool i got to level 50.
there are no fat people in the fourth
dimension
that i can assure you
i'm making a joke i've never seen a fat
person in the fourth dimension that's
ridiculous
how you said that people in the fourth
dimension remember the video of trump
playing the accordion yeah that's so
good i've never seen a thin person in
the third dimension quite very quickly
tim would that be such a bad thing if
this was basically just a big video game
and then you know as avatars vanish and
then the fourth dimensional tim is still
around he gets another shot at it yeah
but what i mean is we are not the fourth
dimensional character we're we're a
projection of them we're
but you're if you when my character
dies it's it's consciousness doesn't
transport into my body and go wow i
remember everything no it's just gone
you're dead but if you're playing the
video game like zelda and link dies you
tim remember the entire experience and
you're link not the player correct not
tim right so tim gets up and leaves and
you link you're gone yeah but it's i
would rather be the player than b-link i
think you're both that's that's what i'm
saying in that situation what i'm saying
if
link in the game i'm so scared of what
the chat's looking like right now does
not have to look at it again i'm so
scared
what i'm saying is based on your logic
you are an avatar for someone else
correct not yourself no when you die you
die there's no you're you're not a
fourth dimensional being a fourth
mentioned being is puppeting you no if
i'm making a video recording of you that
is still a recording of you it's not tim
and link it's video tim and flesh him
what you're describing is more like a
fourth dimensional being has entered the
third dimension yes or yes and what i'm
saying is what if it's not like that
what if it's a fourth dimensional being
taking a controller and controlling you
and then you die he puts the controller
on and leaves okay right i mean like
we're all npcs some are just guided by
no if we're guided then we're the pcs
that's what the pc means yes you but but
you but you don't exist outside of this
world correct but we don't exist outside
this world
oh so that's that's that that's actually
what it is you're not a fourth
dimensional being you're going to define
you right if you're if i'm watching a
videotape of tim that videotaped
character doesn't exist in this
three-dimensional what i thought you
were saying is that the like there's
fourth dimensional beings basically
playing a vr game
so when they take it i'm not sure at all
of the exact relationship at all i
wonder like this if we are apparitions
of a fourth dimensional energy force or
something like why is it twisting
together in the shape that it is why is
matter bound in these boundary
conditions like
skin why does it stop here why why why
is it forming into atoms like where it
is
i don't understand why there must be a
god i mean it must it always comes back
like why there
it can't be no reason i mean maybe it
can well
as as kind of
uh it's hard to describe what you just
said you came to a
i mean a conclusion that you know god i
made statements that i didn't back up
basically and then said no but a lot of
these questions have answers but not
it's it's you know if if we if we talk
about the fundamental forces of the
universe that we think we know as humans
through science subatomic forces or
radiation or gravity or whatever
then there's still questions on where
those forces lead to after that sure
like they're spinning they call them
spinners these sub-atomic things quarks
elephants and so they're spinning and
they form into protons or or electrons
depending on the sub-atomic spin
mechanism but why
i just still haven't figured it out i
got a question sheamus if you think or
suspect that psychedelics have some kind
of demonic
aspect to them does that mean you will
never try them yeah
wow okay
you sure you never never is a pretty
extreme statement never never what if
the church were like mushrooms are now
i don't think they could
i don't think they could this is this
this pope there's a lot this pub can do
am i wrong i'm not i'm not even joking
well so there are certain teachers like
like there are things that
if the church has established something
like as an infallible teaching they
can't go back on it he can add to things
sure or he can you know issue um
statements about administrative things
or his opinion on something but they
can't like reverse a teaching that was
already there i thought they said limbo
no longer exists that's a really good
question so there's there's an argument
about this it's not the case that
catholics can't believe in limbo and as
far as i understand again there are
people far more educated than me on this
who will argue that it is something
catholics should believe it's not
mandated by the church
but
it also wasn't the church taking
something that was in the magisterium
and saying no like the opposite is now
true
um or do they talk about psychonauts and
they don't do it yeah yeah well there's
a passage in the chat because i'm about
drugs
we gotta go to super chat so if you
haven't already argument is psychedelics
on drugs but they're medicine go ahead
smash the like button subscribe to
channel share the show with your friends
if you really like it become a member at
timcast.com to support our work directly
because we are principally supported by
our members i'm going to read
one super chat from the most recent
conversation first before going back to
the beginning
jacob labelle says i only did dmt once i
didn't trip i just blanked out and
collapsed does this mean i'm an npc and
have no soul kind of freaking to be
honest no you're just sitting down when
you're doing this next question
sorry jacob were you standing he said he
collapsed
blanked out and collapsed always be
sitting down i would think if you're
going to do something like that
all right jacob just hit ctrl the lead
here we go we got uh um
bon tito freak says hey tim and crew
i've been trying to reach you guys about
openings for video game artists this is
my ad on twitter to discuss more i've
i've also dmd about it um at guad 27. uh
sheamus
what's going on with that art for that
video game we be we're we're working on
it right now um basically we've been
really slammed but i just got a list of
things from chris and andy that we are
going to try to get patched up so we can
get this thing so uh how can you do
something called freedom tunes and not
once animate the best anarchist ever did
you you've never asked
i've said all right i've hit you up i've
been like malice come on
i think i messaged you a while ago we've
talked about collaborating
did you know that this is the first time
we are we are producing a video to me
sitting across from them
is it called unlucky charms
did we say that yeah well hold on no one
said the luck of the irish was good can
we say the name
all right have we released the name yet
of the game yeah let's keep it all as
much of it might be in the vlog it's
called the troubles yeah that's right
yeah it's uh the game is basically it's
a it's a platformer where you play as
james and you gotta catch your lucky
charms no [ __ ] you have to catch this
caller after the game at all not the
game no not even close all right let's
read some more
w falcon 59 says hey tim here's what may
be some good news cnn plus is
advertising on your show on spotify i
think you won
cnn is like we know that you hate us
please watch us
i just love the idea that cnn is doing
third party advertising on my show
because it's ineffective one hundred
percent cnn if you're listening take
some money i i know i'm like no no
single person who's gonna watch or
listen to this show is also gonna be
like you know i heard an ad for cnn plus
and i decided it's a good thing i'm
convinced yeah all right let's read some
more
where we got
mr grizzly bear says you should call
your coffee shop cast coffee
well all right then
that's terrible
okay
uh oh wait cass like tip cast okay
that's better okay i'm intelligent also
i was talking to earlier when when uh
starbucks announced that they were
supporting the uh the protest against
parental rights education daily wire
says they're gonna do their own kids
content i was like why don't we open our
own coffee coffee chain yeah you open
one and you just open more you know what
to call it
cast coffee no the coffee beanie
that's right
all right daniel ashley says love to see
michael malus
there you go
anthony rondanelli says congrats on your
500th episode love you all here is to
500 more yeah right all right
okay some of these
uh super chats i just can't read they're
confusing to me so i'm just going to go
past them
just
mentioning that michael looks really
good today oh yeah beautiful yeah he
does what else is new all right i am an
underwear model that's right true yeah
durafiddy says if sheamus ever does the
jordan peterson prank calls he needs to
ask for red lobster gift cards oh my god
that is true you have to go you need to
go to red lobster right now listen to me
we've accidentally over deposited in
your account by ten thousand dollars it
was an accident he's got to be like my
car's broken down
and i need your help
you know and they're like how do i help
just go to red lobster and buy get you
know go to walmart get it you need red
lobster gift cards you have to sell them
to me now
all right
dan karna says which journal would be
press secretary malice's most formidable
foe
formidable that's a great great question
um
i i don't i can't think of anyone off
the top of my head because
i think that if someone had tough
questions
i would honestly say let me get back to
you let me do the research and i'd want
to give them that information because if
they're coming at me honestly with
journalism i i would respect them so i i
can't think of it what's up my head all
right
here we go
it's a evil zombie hamster says finally
paid off the truck last week here's this
paycheck's truck payment to something
worthy of it love you guys especially
lord ian ruler of one square foot in
scotland oh you're right keep up the
good work guys i'm always excited when i
hear sheamus's voice on here it's always
a good episode oh thank you and that is
true i am a scottish lord i bought a one
foot by one foot square piece of land in
scotland lord you call me lordy
modern-day count dankula
lost valley says
uh malice at the cast castle aka malice
in the palace you know it there was a
bar in new york called nomalis palace
where i had my birthday one year that's
awesome
all right that's true anarchism
[Laughter]
disneyland lifer and disney parks fan
here not a disney fan went back into the
park in july there were new faces and
unfriendly environment the cms and
lifers have suspected since before the
pandemic that corporate has been up to
something
you know what you know i've been
mentioning recently i did a segment on
this today
that uh have you seen the people on tick
tock acting like uh
animated characters no no there's
something called like the 12 principles
of animation
and this trend emerged where
young people started acting like they're
in disney pixar films
so you know the characters in those
things yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so they
started doing it and now young people
are actually
literally adopting the behavior because
they see tick tockers doing it good lord
so
they're they're developing like
ticks yeah almost and so like the 12
principles of animation are in large
part to make your visuals look more
lifelike but it's also the case that in
animation you want your poses to read
really well so you'll have them move in
ways that a person wouldn't move in real
life just to communicate the expression
right so for example like
ideally the expression should be
recognizable via silhouette if you
didn't see that person's face you should
just be able to tell from their body how
they're feeling it's it's very um
like almost vaudevillian yeah yeah yeah
yes exactly that's the same in theater
when you're at the interactor you make
your arms huge because you want to
project and it doesn't translate on on
video which you can see with these
people
the coffee beanie yeah and we'll open a
bunch and we'll just be like we're not
playing any stupid woke stuff we're just
going to sell
cappuccinos or something caffeine would
you like would you like a sour lid on
that yeah i really i want to make bowls
that are upside down beanies because i
wanted to pour lucky charms
yeah i want to pack it with lucky charms
that's right michael
people i'm not even kidding about this
i'm not even kidding about opening a
chain of coffee shops i love the idea
because i was talking about doing a
sandwich shop before
so that we could just do whatever we
wanted it would be so amazing to have
subsidized sandwich shop where i can
like a karen comes in and is like there
was too much mayonnaise and all that and
i wonder if you could buy it i want it
fixed a coffee farm in south america buy
one buy a coffee farm in south america
and just import your own coffee
you know we'll do we'll do we'll set up
the first store
and it'll be uh the the the coffee
beanie a physical location that sells
just coffee goods like starbucks would
but we exclusively source quickly coffee
brilliant which is great coffee by the
way curricular coffee
why are you laughing i don't know
all right let's read some more super
chats um
scott james says happy 500th episode to
shim cast irl and shout out to ian on
the chrissy mayer podcast fun episode
also at tim and ian give babylon 5 a
watch if you like ds9 then you should
like b5 ds9 actually ripped it off look
it up okay
i also nerd
i would just like for everyone to take a
moment to reflect on shim cast reaching
its 500th episode what an achievement
that is for me you've done a really good
job
all right the teeth grinder says
umpteenth unread super chat with a
crying face and then he says michael's
cosplay wins today's internet massive
love and hugs to tim lid's ian sheamus
luke and absentia and all that tim cast
from great britain i don't i don't know
what he means by michael's cosplay
though what is it what are you talking
about i mean something is different in
british oh yeah it's like the hood of a
car austin translation
yeah oh okay that makes sense sorry
otherwise thank you
winking walrus says you guys hear about
alabama constitutional carry like a
couple weeks ago goes into effect
january 1st cool so next year
but this is what half the country now
constitutional carry yeah 25 states i
believe
all right dragon lady says happy 500th
so sheamus will you ever do more
debunkers videos spent several hours
last night watching them they're great
and guys what happened with the blurry
chicken city cam this morning finally
malice you rock uh chicken city camera
got wet and so we just swapped it out
and because outside cameras break and we
are producing more debunker videos those
are a lot of fun i know we haven't done
one in over a year but what are they i
don't know about these oh so one of our
videos that we'll release or one of the
series we do is it's these two
intellectuals who sit in their bunker
they're hiding from the general public
because they don't want to catch the
stupid in order to stay sharp they watch
youtube videos and debunk them
and so that we'll we'll take videos that
have a lot of nonsense in them that are
popular and being shared around and
we'll have them watch it and pause the
video and then comment on it
explain liberty and there there honestly
there's a lot of research that goes into
those which is part of why it's it's
difficult to put them together but we
have a couple of them in the works right
now are those freedom tunes also yeah
they're on the freedom tunes channel so
from an animation perspective they're
much easier but from a writing and
research perspective they're much more
difficult all right liberty or death
says malice looks like a
post-apocalyptic version of tim poole
from a star trek episode who came
through a temporal distortion to warn us
about the marxist yeah i think it's the
beard yeah which looks great by the way
i i can't wait to shave this
i've been so for two weeks oh man
well you can always uh get a jeremy's
razor that's true from the daily wire
crew that's that's true that's a great
point yeah that's a great idea
g says
when did tim get a twin what do you mean
ian's been on the show for a while yeah
at least a year and a half yeah two
years ago she's saying they all look
alike yeah i don't know maybe
well
well i actually are you you're irish
right i am is that true and german yeah
why don't you guys insult him about this
you know what's crazy i i know that it
is considered in bad days like people
what's his name from ireland i know it's
not my fault i didn't pick this for
myself you should pick up here we go
trust that one sideways says malice not
liking anime dang man that's a real
boomer cringe take you just went from a
pretty cool guy to i guess he's all
right he's got some good ideas and makes
me giggle lmao
yeah you rep x hard thank you sir yeah
hey look at that true patriot says
michael malus for press secretary after
saki leaves
dave smith has not returned two texts
and two emails uh-oh
information yeah he's too busy like
walking with like a camera shot like the
west wing as he's preparing i i i wanted
to get him on my show last week i can't
get a hold of him he has two kids now
like teddy roosevelt yeah but i'm more
important than his children you know
teddy roosevelt while he was in office
would just leave the white house for
weeks at a time and go hunting and no
one knew where he was
yeah he would leave for like at least a
week at a time i don't know okay oh here
we go president yeah while he was
president they were like where is he ian
kenny says thomas massey hold on i know
that's not okay i will even get lost for
like two weeks i'm gonna double check
that because i've heard that uh i know
he was he didn't leave america so if
he's hunting no you'd hunt out you might
go out west that might be possible make
sense
tim's checking something nice yeah some
uh ian kennedy says thomas massie and
justin amash tweeted about the more act
if you want to know cool
thank you guys
amash is a cool dude i was just on his
podcast couple weeks i've met him yet
awesome massey's great if he didn't
messian followed me because he got
butthurt when i was making jokes about
ron paul jokes about ron paul they're
about joe biden thomas mazzy said the
more act is supposed to make marijuana
more legal but it creates more crimes
more federal taxes more government spend
spending and more central planning yeah
the federal taxes yep yeah but it makes
more crimes probably through texas yeah
yeah i think so so i i knew there was
going to be something about it some
catch it looks so good at face value
they're so good at that at crafting of
course
good
that's their biggest skill i know making
evil things seem like how could you
possibly be against this not only their
biggest skill they're only one yeah it
really is yeah all right orange juice
410 404 says listening to yesterday's
irl episode google podcasts i find it
ironic that an ad for cnn plus played
and i quote quote get access to live
news and shows from trusted journalists
talk about out of touch i just love the
idea that someone at cnn was like can we
buy ads on tim timpool's show he really
hates us
like what are they what do they think
they must have bought a mass batch for
sure probably or maybe they probably
said news and politics yeah yeah exactly
but good good i'm glad they're doing it
when bloomberg did that big campaign and
people were like tim bloomberg ads are
appearing on your videos and i was like
great yeah because it's basically this
you can watch a video game video and get
a bloomberg ad and then you're just
listening to bs or you can listen to a
bloomberg ad and then see me debunk it
yeah yeah so good i'll take his money i
just i want to shamelessly self-promote
here but when those ads were going out
we made a freedom tunes cartoon about
his ads i really want you guys to go
check that one's awesome yeah yeah
tim's doing the research again yeah it
was barack obama that told me not me
directly that roosevelt would go and
leave the white house for like a week at
a time i like it barack obama told me
yeah
directly i'm like what the heck
i found barack obama on a run a hunting
trip he's like uh roosevelt used to do
it yeah
obama got in he was like my favorite
president is abraham lincoln and then
when he left he said my favorite
president was teddy roosevelt because
when he came in he was ready to do it
and whatever it took and then he got
co-opted and he's like no no no let's
just be the boisterous yeah that he said
those things roosevelt got shot and he
finished the speech
all right we got venice beach dub club
lydia that's dark it's true you were
advocating for obama no good lord we all
heard it my gosh all right michael thank
you all right you're welcome you might
finish the speech venice beach dub club
says tim's theory about dmt amount uh
dmt amount present in your system
relating to your connection to god
equals midichlorians and the force from
star wars episode one oh god is everyone
watching the show a nerd uh yeah i hated
that miracle-oriented thing did you guys
know right could you imagine being as
uncultured
dude what if you could have so much dmt
access that you were a jedi
that's the most ian thing i've ever yeah
there's like uh
there's like a chemical like a like a
russian military chemical called amt a
methyltryptamine which is apparently
like the limitless drug where people
will be like for 12-hour states they'll
have like everything we'll synchronize
and
create like a guy like ayahuasca
i don't know i think it's more like dmt
but like it's like it's like ayahuasca
oh yeah yeah yeah ayahuasca makes you
produce long-form dmt yeah
all right kkc says tim trying to
describe dmt in the multiverse just
feels like the time lords and the
untempered schism but with more steps by
the way i want to say something that's
going to upset every single person
listening to this and everyone in this
room which is we are about two years out
three years out from corporate
psychedelics
which is gonna be the biggest nightmare
that has ever existed and they're gonna
be in the metaverse with psychedelics oh
god i know i think we're headed but i
think there's
i've
i don't think it's too much of a stretch
at all because there is not a stretch
there's something very consumerist about
the idea too of course about the idea of
of taking psychedelics in general like i
have a product i can give you that will
give you spiritual enlightenment like it
is a product you will take it and
they're they're out they're already
touring they're already tourists to
reality to begin with so it's not much
of a stretch at all
brandon lesko says we're from the 4d
government and we're here to help thank
you brandon is there a fourth
dimensional government brought the
machine ls yeah yeah the
u.n
all right bobcat says what are those
going to be like okay i don't know if
you want to break
achieve enlightenment oh my god
sponsored by whole foods
lucky charms with dmg bobcat says as a
tim cast member i would like to thank
tim the science pool for giving failed
cartoonists like shame as a job in these
trying times first of all tip cape to be
begging sheamus they're gonna turn the
lights out they're gonna turn them out i
need another role i said i created a
character i said what if he's a little
little little little gremlin type they
doctor fouchy he's a fud character
people love him it's how tim got his
name okay
auntie c says the book of hebrews in the
bible says this world is a shadow of the
original heaven oh is that right in
heaven what what verse is that true
shamus i looked up the verse in
translation i'm not sure
what what book of the bible is that the
book of hebrews and the bible wow
this world is a shadow of the original i
believe that's correct i i truly believe
that they were on psychedelics we heard
you daily and you believe everyone's
psychotic i thought that it was like a
part of their diet like it was they were
always on it if that was true they would
still be on it because judaism really
has kept a straight line in many ways
from those times especially the people
to hi at the top the couple religious
ones like the kabbalah that's middle
ages that came much later
all right adam milne says michael should
reach out to destiny for an interview
his recent twitch ban would be a
fantastic conversation for you're
welcome okay you're familiar with
destiny i know the name
they brought i did a live stream i was
signing books uh with blairishness
helped me in in la and uh people said i
should have him on the show yeah i think
you never really i i said it wouldn't be
a bad idea because i know he's done
jesse lee peterson's show and they had a
good time he's uh uh he he i think he
knows a lot he knows what he's talking
about would you recommend him yeah
that's all i need to hear okay he's but
he's more of like an establishment lefty
kind of personality as long as he's not
going to be an ass i'm fine with it well
i mean
what i don't
how do you describe destiny he's
aggressive it's i mean he's going to be
am i going to regret having him he's
verbose i i don't think so but he's
really enjoying him yeah if we disagree
i don't care i just don't need him to be
like like a jerk about it so we had him
here and he talked about
how uh uh covid and the emergency is the
perfect time to have government come in
and and make all these changes because
when else would you do it he's that's
true he's pro woke uh so he's he's he
knows what critical race theory is and
he he likes and agrees with it and he
also said cal written house was the
clearest cut case of self defense he's
ever seen so okay anyone who is even a
little like in on their own path i i
like those kind of people yeah i don't
agree with them and twitch bans him all
the time because
he doesn't how do i reach out i'll i'll
i'll figure out how to get hold of him
but um i think you guys have a great
conversation okay that's a no-brainer
then yeah you know we had him here a lot
of people thought it was going to be
this like generic right versus left or
like libertarian or authoritarian and
it's like we agreed on a lot of things
yeah i i love getting i get along very
well thread belt leftist even if they're
a little bit red pilled i don't know if
he's a leftist though i mean maybe he is
if he's for critical race theory he's
not a right winger that's true yeah yeah
all right nos says some people who are
religious think that we are spiritual
beings having a human experience we come
to this earth to have a hum to have
human experiences maybe from the dmt
source idk
so did you look up the shadow thing in
hebrews uh let me pull it up i i
looked it up immediately
back to the conversation um i'm also not
sure which verse they're referring to
just look up the word shadow in that
chapter in that book rather shadow
all right sargon of assyria says
[Laughter]
what well is that a sargon of akkad
sargon
everyone it is the assyrian new year it
is still celebrated in northern iraq
assyria with the help of gesheru.com
many of us in
in diaspora get to celebrate this
festival with our people back home this
podcast is amazing thank you all heart
hey thank you very much thanks man yeah
and shout out to all the refugees from
iraq and iran who are making it happen
uh they can't live in their homeland so
i can relate to that
all the cool persons out there forrest
horlacker says whoa join the late and
feel like i'm the one who's high with
all the drug god talk and seeing two
tims love y'all keep up the good fight
even michael if you're seeing two tims
maybe something's wrong with your eyes
keep up the good fight even michael
wow what does that mean she didn't need
the support or something oh okay
michael who hates fighting
or is only on the bad fight
brett ain't dead says smoked dmt
multiple times one time i was abducted
taken into space my soul in between the
space time in in between the space
between space
chanted to in a language older than time
we are energy finite i did it by myself
fyi god is real
how would you liken it michael i guess
you have maybe more experience than
anyone here with it particularly to a
dream to dimethyl trip to me no i don't
okay imagine that you did okay how would
you liken it to a dream
i i my understanding is it's extremely
different because dreams are much more
ephemeral uh you can't really remember
it sometimes you know and i think when
people break the veil they know they're
breaking the veil when you're dreaming
you don't always know you're dreaming
and the dre i think dreams are less
coherent than dmt trips
i've never dmt tripped but um a long
time ago i did a bunch of things to to
make it so that you you lose a dream
more often and so like basically all of
my dreams are lucid dreams but there's
like basic things you do one you're like
wearing a watch all the time and then
you'll just like snap it and so then
when you have a dream you'll look at
your wrist and you'll see it and you'll
be like this is not working right i'm
dreaming and instantly you come out of
it and there's other things you can do
it's called walking into a dream it's
where you just use your imagination as
you're going to sleep and craft the
dream as you enter the sleep state so
these are things that i'd be interested
to see studies on dmt experience while
you're already sleeping to have it like
an injection in someone that's a great
question oh yeah yeah who's doing those
studies i think in england they've been
doing some extended state stuff i don't
know
but how can we trust the studies what if
they're just saying the study happened
but they took dmt and wrote down the
hallucinations i got to do it for myself
to know yeah exactly he didn't get it oh
wait yeah i was already confirmed that
i'm going to do it myself first i'd have
to in that case all right i got your
[ __ ] forced name change says hey guys we
live in a 3d universe consisting of
three axis at 90 degrees to each other
there is one more dimension at 90
degrees to these inwards that's why you
feel a spirit in you and makes black
holes for the objects
yeah it's a spiral that one going in
it's not a straight line in none of
those lines are straight in the three
dimensional the z x y z axis none of
them are straight lines they seem
straight but they're not and the one
going in is like a corkscrew i think
they can expand and contract
but then i guess they all could paul
mcgrath says in the bible the word for
witchcraft can be translated as
pharmaceutical
or just as translated pharmaceutical is
that what you mean
that seems crazy
i don't know about it i'm interested in
the citation you still haven't found it
yeah well so i pulled i i just searched
book of hebrews and shadow and i found
two verses so far neither of which seem
to say that the the world is a shadow so
i'm still looking we got trump we got
trolled i'm looking forward to because i
have to be
careful
says the irishman's dilemma what should
i eat the potato now or should i wait
for it to ferment and drink it later oh
it's really offensive
it's not a dilemma you wait for it to
ferment come on but irish people don't
drink vodka yeah someone made that joke
how is it that you live in a country
where the all the uh
food is based on potatoes you can't
figure out vodka
i forgot who that was it was honestly
that's because he already had enough
whiskey yeah
k goblin says the bible was written by a
series of multiple authorities separated
over time across the centuries cripping
off the last edits made authority
definitely had an influence just not one
authority
that's what i thought it was but i mean
the original authorities were just the
people that hung out with jesus it
depends like how are they defining
authorities like are they saying
government authorities got down and
wrote this i'm not sure what their point
is because that's not the case who was
the originals like were they jesus's
friends
um so it depends on the book you're
talking about you keep going through the
stream matthew mark luke and john you
know matthew jesus is friends
yeah he's great but were they like after
him
you know
i knew him when he was saul
yeah yeah so they wrote about the
stories about jesus they weren't like
his his company all his compatriots got
slaughtered right no they wrote like
they a lot of them the new testament
yeah gosh okay yes yes i'm such a noob
yeah
a lot of his friends i was going to say
i found a verse in hebrews 8 4 and 5. it
says for if he were on earth he would
not be a priest at all seeing there are
priests who offer the gifts according to
the torah who serve a copy and a shadow
of the heavenly things even as moses was
warned by god when he was about to make
the tabernacle for he said see you shall
make everything according to the pattern
that was shown you on the mountain so i
don't see that as being no not at all
that's saying more that they're they're
doing a
pale reflection of reality right which
is still real like they're being phony
right yeah so it's not it's not a fool
it's not exactly what they're saying all
right david robinson says machine elves
are beings taking dmt and telling their
friends about the flesh dwarves they
talk
that makes sense and they says please
have justin amash on
we haven't but perhaps we will i was
very critical of him in the past because
he came out hard against trump at a time
when i felt that trump was being
unfairly maligned in the press
they just they keep asking about it he
has a very good
argument for it um so i i i like him
he's grown on me a lot considering he's
he's done some made some good votes i
was i was you know like oh all right
interesting you know but i i remember
like his first thing was just being like
the republicans are bad and you know
coming out and and it's like well he's
not wrong no his point when i was just
on his podcast he goes more presidents
should be impeached he's like we let
them get away with too much and that was
actually a good argument it is it is um
and the republicans are trash it's just
there are some good people who run as
republicans right democrats are trash as
well
they're substantially less good people
who run as democrats but i don't know
tulsi did for whatever reason although
they call her right wings where's she
gonna run in hawaii you have to run as a
democrat right exactly yeah
and she's a lefty i mean she's first
hardcore welfare state socialized you
know you know but she believes in the
truth yeah so that means she's right
wing and she doesn't like war g says
ezekiel 1 uh 148 could this be ian's
machine elves probably not but it will
blow ian's mind one one four eight
ezekiel one one four eight one called
ian wants his mind blown he needs to be
the book of enoch which is apocryphal
yeah but that has all the stuff is that
where he goes to space or something no
that's where the nephilim are and it's
like yeah it's like yeah oh the nephilim
aren't in the bible there's one verse of
them only and they're it's not clear
what they are
they're not in the bible yeah
aren't they like uh
angel human hybrids but that's the
question there's a verse about the yeah
the the sons of god or something like
that um
but there's just there's one word and so
people that describe it and it's
mysterious and so because it's
mysterious people have just extrapolated
so many explanations for it over the
years why is the book of enoch
apocryphal because it's not the count i
see in council said this isn't bible so
it is bible but they just said no but
that's not a bible the bible is what has
been the bible officially validated as
the books of the bible right so it's
also authoritarian there's also the the
youthful gospel of christ i figured
something was called thomas and stuff
yeah yeah
so you're saying the book of enoch was
like fan fiction and they're like get
out of here that's not cannon
kind of i wouldn't say
there were just there were different
accounts that were either determined to
were determined to be unreliable for
whatever reason or not holy scripture or
it doesn't add up to the rest of the
stuff it's interesting is that i think
there's verses in the bible that refer
to books that have been deemed
apocryphal so that was kind of an issue
for them thank you yes uh enoch was
noah's grandfather yeah polaris 589 says
get michael malus and john mattingly on
at the same time
oh no i don't want world war three it
wouldn't be world war three it would be
slaughtering a pig
choice words
daniel thompson says john manley those
don't know he's the cop we just uh we
had on he was in the brianna taylor and
you got it you had him on yeah the other
day oh my god your numbers must have
been zero oh it was the biggest show
we've ever had
everybody was like this guy's so much
better than michael
that's about right
daniel thompson says first time super
chatter you should have jennifer ruth
green on your show she is a conservative
running in the first district in indiana
she's a 20 year old air force veteran
that has a good chance of flipping the
district interesting
yeah well you want to write down
jennifer ruth green just don't know
that's fun
i'd love to get some you know like sane
honest democrats
i think they're all republicans now i
know for real at least not democrats or
then but they'd have a huge cost coming
on here i know they won't do it look
tulsi gabbard wants gun control and she
wants she opposes nuclear energy there's
a bunch of things that are just very
much in line with the left but then
she's like oh that stuff they report in
the news about hunter biden is true and
they're like she's conservative no she's
a russian asset right she's a russian
agent that she's pro-putin only someone
who's pro-putin would say that these
aren't photoshop photos of him with a
ruler next to his genitals wow exactly
lumberjack says i can totally relate to
mr malice nerds nerds nerds thank you
lumberjack i'm also lumberjack and i'm
okay that's not an insult that's just a
fact of life i agree with that so say
the lobster lumberjack this is the way
star trek or star wars star wars do you
don't get me started are you kidding if
you look at the by oh god this is like
the fourth time i have to give this
speech if you look at the biodiversity
just on earth's deep sea
right and then you look at star trek
where they go other planets and it's a
guy who's got blue skin are you kidding
me listen to this guy who doesn't know
anything about star trek i don't need to
know that's all i had i knew enough and
i'm like i'm out of here bro where's
star wars look at the jabba's palace
look at those
faces let me let me correct you
you incorrect man
the first highly logical the first
mistake you're making is is when people
compare starter to star wars is the
first mistake star wars they just asked
me to compare them yeah and and right
this is the first mistake right so this
is not on you star wars is a fantasy
adventure star trek is naval naval
tradition and civil libertarianism
explored through the lens of
technological advancement and and
cultural development in other worlds the
reason why uh uh in star trek
everybody's humanoid is it's it's it's
we can't afford it it was it was the 60s
and they just put people in costumes and
the budgets were so trash that sometimes
the star trek crew just go into like a
white room and it was like oh we're in a
because they have the budget for it do
you know why you can't watch star trek
in florida
you can what do you mean because it's
gay
have you have you watched star trek i i
i yes very little of it i hate it
have you you've not watched like the
next generation with nerd that's the
good one that's the one i like this is
this is the issue you're so
closed-minded michael
okay i'm fine with it what the show
if you think you're gonna watch star
trek and get a star wars like experience
with people force pushing and laser
sorting you're wrong what star trek is
is a captain and a commander with naval
traditions saying
uh terrorists have engaged this planet
how do we deal with it data the android
is like i don't understand why you're so
resistant to terrorism why it's
considered wrong when it's been so
effective throughout history such as in
these particular moments and they're
like how do we deal with this problem or
there's one where this is you're not
selling it to me the state tries to
seize the child and captain picard says
forcing a man to give up his child to
the state not while i'm captain and
they're sitting down having a
conversation about why it's wrong for
the state to claim dominion over
someone's children okay it's not laser
swords it's literally a guy being like
free speech what's the what's the favor
there's there's there's so much good
[ __ ] uh there is you got me swearing now
you got um when when when the first
chain of the link is forged the first
word censured we are all irrevocably
chained or whatever it's a great quote
then there's also this the story line
where picard is being tortured and i
know how he felt and he's got he's got
there's there's four lights at the table
i know there's three lights yeah i get
it there's four lights okay and it's
just like you got to watch it i think
i'm the more of a star wars guy just
because the force i think it's real but
star wars is like i'm going to defeat
the evil
dooku and star jack is like the first
three after that bro in deep state's
nine there's like a
a war is breaking out they're trying to
convince another faction to join them so
they stage a false flag attack on a
senator from romulan empire to trick
them into joining the war on their side
okay it's just amazing it's politics if
you like politics you'd like it i i
don't know about that oh man i i don't
know i feel like you could take a lot of
the sci-fi uh the sci-fi backdrop out of
it and you're just watching the
exploration of ideas around political
times then why they have a guy with a
wrinkle on his head and call him an
alien yeah that's a good question it's
just it's just a mechanism for for for
having these plots around philosophical
philosophical concepts and and ethics
morals and technology and
to tell you the story to spoil it for
you it's because the progenitors seeded
their dna throughout the galaxy
panspermia but you see you get lost in
the sci-fi instead of exploring the
political uh uh the political i'm very
skeptical that a syndicated show is
going to be
treat these issues in a way that i would
find interesting
when
the admiral tells picard you are
jeopardizing your command and career
because he's refusing to give someone's
child to the state and then he says
there comes a time when men of good
conscience will defy orders given to
hand over to force a man to hand his
child over to the state not while i'm
captain okay it's amazing i agree i'm
sitting there i'm like yes i know that's
why you'd love it because because so
much of what you believe would be
reflected and explored through like
in certain
in certain situations where you'd be
like wow you know these ideas
conflicting and how they're clash and
how you resolve them okay i'm gonna have
to like get people to like raise like a
grand and then i'll watch about the
first six episodes
uh the challenge is there's something
called riker's beard you ever hear of
this concept oh god no because you don't
jump into the story yes of course
riker's beard is the opposite it's
something that's good it's when things
get good so in the second season it's
when jonathan frank grew a beard and the
show really started first season was
really not gonna convince me that things
get better when someone grows a beard i
assure you it gets much much worse and i
speak from experience their acting was
really uh rigid in the first season
everyone was standing really still
didn't really know each other as people
like they were just working together as
actors this you can tell they're getting
to know each other in the but bro like
the ferengi you're the frankie are you
aren't they
the me
yes yeah they're they're they're like
their motto is caveat emptor yeah it's
it's amazing they they didn't develop
war protect so here's how it works
civilizations will develop warp
technology allowing faster than light
travel the federation then greets them
around this time like you're now
entering the galactic community we're
going to talk to you the ferengi bought
it they figured out how to trade and
manipulate their way into technology
they're not culturally developed enough
to understand it's it's such
such brilliant writing across the board
there's some bad stuff voyager is kind
of in but you you know what man is
voyager with the girl voyager it's the
first time that a female captain in the
entire plot is they get lost and they
have to make their way back home that's
the whole series
the the literally the first episode they
get lost in the whole series as they're
trying to get back to be fair a powerful
entity sucks them something like seven
seventy three was that that is always an
excuse was that a powerful empty entity
a clothing sale yeah maybe
come on gals grab your purses i think i
think you need to find someone to just
be like here watch one episode because
you probably wouldn't like all of it
okay but there's like such good
political moments in it i'll i'll raise
a grand and i'll watch three perfect
okay if you recorded yourself watching i
will be commenting i don't like it i
will pay you a thousand dollars to do a
live like do a reaction as you watch i
will watch them with an open mind yes
and we'll i want to like it yeah
i like it there's a lot of material
doesn't really sound like you want to
like i don't know i want to like it it
just seems everything i've seen makes me
seem better because i would i love i
love looking for new shows to watch yeah
legendary so many times so check it out
so in the original series there's the
bad guys the klingons that's like bad
guys in the next generation all of a
sudden there's like a klingon on the
federation ship they're good guys now
what they wrote was
their uh the klingons are an honor
culture they're very much you have to
have honor and be a warrior
so uh there's another race called the
romulans it's based on like roman
style and they're passion driven so uh
one day or stardate or whatever the
romulans are attacking a klingon
civilian colonial outpost and they sent
off a distress signal the uh
earlier version of the enterprise
responds to their enemy the klingons
distress signal to try and save the
women and the children and end up dying
in an effort to save people from this
romulan attack
and the klingons see that as an
honorable you know it's honor and they
see the romulans as a dishonorable and
that creates the alliance between the
klingon empire very noble of you to
refer as klingons as people
yes yes anyway thanks for hanging out
everybody uh make sure you smash the
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends go to
timcast.com become a member you can
follow us at tim cast irl you can follow
me at timcast michael you want to shout
anything out um michael malus on twitter
michaelmouseofficial on youtube um and
i'm really glad to have done this i'll
see you guys soon absolutely yeah this
was a great time um i want to mention
and shout out 1776 flag company who made
this yes as a gift for tim cass the
place behind me thank you very much uh
and i want to shout out my cartoon
freedom tunes please go check it out i
think you guys will enjoy it uh also i
want to
circle back to your show you're welcome
which always never disappoints always is
awesome very intelligently done and
that's on youtube is that just a search
for your welcome without the apostrophe
yes i like that it's possessive yeah i'm
ian crossland catch you later thank you
guys very much for tuning in for our
500th episode with michael mallis i am
loving the new look i think that you
should make this permanent gonna gonna
go with it it's gonna be great stick
with it michael you guys may follow me
on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlets thanks for hanging out
everybody we will see you all over at
chicken city go to youtube.com chicken
city right now to watch our chickens and
subscribe and you can also check out the
cast castle because we have daily vlogs
other than that we'll be back with the
show on monday thanks for hanging out
bye guys
you